You see, they have evidence that the child was asking for it
very aggressively. Someone asked Preacher
The other user responds, "All right, since I'm 13,
I'm maybe good for now anyway. Sam." >> Every every single
weeb in an Asmongold adjacent community is just Roman Polanski
to them. They'll die on every
Anyway, this person is a groomer.
>> [__] So, this all started off with
this person put Nux in the video. This person's a friend of Nux.
They're they're a watcher, a Nux viewer, okay. And they explicitly
kind of were sweeping for Nux in a way that was upsetting to
Nux specifically, but I'm sure some other people, too. All right.
Let's start with this first clip. Basically, they hadn't watched
the video at all, and they were basically just saying, "I don't
really care. I don't know what's happening. Blah blah blah blah
blah." >> Is Nux still being really [__] canceled?
Dude, I don't even know. I don't even know the Nux situation
at all, to be honest. But, I'm going to guess it's really stupid.
That's what I'm going to guess. Yeah, I don't know what's going
on with Nux. Like, I mean, I I I don't know the story behind
it, but I'm pretty sure that the drama's probably done. There's
probably a lot of misunderstandings. That's
So, this is right after the video dropped that they were saying
this. Maybe 3 or 4 days, right? Well, probably no more. I think
it was Nux's birthday like the 9th or something, and then the
So, about a week. You're not You're not supporting Nux, and you
have watched him for 2 years? So, what happened, man? Okay, is
there a video? Actually, I I You know what? To be honest, I don't
even want to get involved in any of this drama. I'm just being
real.
I just don't want
I just don't care. Enough. Wow.
Nux was in the Epstein files? Damn.
Is Nux still Okay, that's not true. Now, there's this person
Godot, Godu, Godo
who is posting somebody under some of the Leafy responses. Surely
atLeafy, who's previously expressed her disgust at grooming and
exposing minors to porn, will not refuse an invitation to discuss
whether one of the people she associates with is guilty of the
same actions. >> monetize the video. However, for some
reason, which we'll talk about later, YouTube doesn't enforce
them. Trust me, you'll need >> This is grooming, bro. They're
100% like they're 100% exposing their fetishes to kids. That's
what this is. He did. Because after clicking on this video, everything
went Oh, boy. Oh, that's kind of What do you even do? How did
they continue to defend after this? How do you differentiate
What How do you differentiate at all? What is this? This is disgusting.
Oh, this is the
I know who this person is kind of from some previous drama. Were
they doing the same thing? Like some kind of grooming thing?
So, totally willing to dis- to totally discredit it and and disavow
this behavior when it's people you don't like, don't care about,
aren't close to. Totally dis- totally like disavow it, discredit
these people, get them out of here. I can see clearly, but as
soon as it's someone you know, things change.
Okay, we're going through the tweets with Leafy here. So, they
first respond
the throwaway clip here.
The idea that I should give a take when I don't even know the
story from the accused side and without don't even know the story
from the accused side and without viewing any evidence at all
myself is I even treated the Ten situation exactly the same with
this consistency. The fact that you guys can't understand this
is the reason you're all faking gay. Yeah, I would just imagine
you probably should look into it, right?
Without dismissing?
You should probably look into it without
All right? Speaking of dismissing, here's one of their follow-up
tweets to this one, okay? So, they're they're responding and
then they say this with like nothing
Um 90% of society's problems can be solved by parents doing their
job and actually raising their kids.
Right? Right?
This is obviously, I think it's an obvious extension of their
comments on the Nux thing saying, "Well, actually, if you if
these parents just did their job, then it wouldn't even be a
problem, guys. It wouldn't be a problem at all." So, that's what
they're trying to do. They're trying to imply that like, "Hey,
these parents weren't doing their job and it's all on the parents,
okay?"
Rough part of that is when you let someone look after your kids
and they turn out to be a Nux Taku mod. This is funny that there
was a guy Well, I think I think this is referencing something
that's public now. I think there's a guy in the Nux server
was looking after kids, which is just a little awkward given
what else was going on in there. He's like a daycare supervisor
or some [__] okay?
Very awkward, very very very awkward. Okay, do I have these I
don't know if I have these in order or not.
So, we have this this guy right here. This is It's not Nux All
right, this is Chronic Sonic, okay? Leap Loop believes parents
are at fault for minors being groomed in Nux Taku's Patreon Discord
server. Oh, right there, okay. Question, if the kid wandered
on a Discord server and you can just you can just groom them
and it will be the parents' fault? Uh, dude, grooming them is
immoral and yes, it is the parents' fault. Both can be simultaneously
true. Well, I mean,
technically, if you're saying it's the parents' fault, it's the
parents share some blame, sure.
You might even say that the parents are the first line of defense.
I would agree with all of that. But unfortunately, it's like
It doesn't make it You still criticize the people who let it
happen on the Discord. If you know the person who let it happen
on the Discord and you're trying to offload to the parents, I
think I see what he's doing or I see I think I see what you're
doing, rather. Yes, I caught dribbled down on it if it's true
that it's the parents' fault, I guess.
What if What is it with bad faith actors always acting like there
can only be one side to take all the blame? I'm just letting
them straw man me and see cuz it's interesting to observe. Okay,
so this is all fine
if you're going to condemn the behavior from Nux, right? Parents
would be the last line of defense. Um
I think parents should be like parent proactive parenting would
be the first line technically the people who have a barrier between
them their kids in the device, but I I think regardless of where
you put them um everybody should act like they're the first line
of defense. Everybody should be doing their part. If there's
something you can do to prevent kids from getting groomed or
prevent kids from being exposed to or material not appropriate
for minors, you should do that. You should obviously do that.
It's incumbent on every single person in a society to do that,
obviously, right? That you shouldn't just say because those parents
are asleep at the wheel and they let their kid do something on
the internet. That doesn't mean you should be allowed or you
should be forgiven or you should have your responsibility diminished
for showing them or showing them something that's inappropriate
for minors. Yeah? Pretty obvious.
I think we we literally all agree on this. I'm sure even the
Leafy person agrees on this when it's not Nux, one of the people
that close to that's being accused. So here's more tweets here.
I don't know why I don't have the Nux Tuber one. I've got to
have it in here
They don't tell you this, but if a minor wanders into a Discord
server, you can just them. Some people got very mad about this.
This is an important one cuz I do believe that this comes up
later in later tweets, later videos, this tweet will come up.
They they did not like this. Their community did not like this.
Their community see it about this tweet, okay?
They were not fans.
Not exactly a direct quote from Nux's from Nux's defense, but
identical in principle, it's the parents' fault. They don't tell
They don't tell you this, but if a minor wanders into a Discord
server, you can just them. I quadrupled down on it. So he's mocking
mocking. You're so dumb it's unreal, actually.
Go ahead, tell me how I'm wrong. That's literally your stance,
identical in principle. Well, I don't know. They're like not
saying what their stance is on Nux's culpability. They could
say that oh well, I actually think Nux is totally to blame, but
it is a dismissal. It's an obvious dismissal, right? If you If
all you say is, well, the parents should do something, and you
say nothing else, even though Nux is clearly culpable for a ton
of bad [__] you're you're trying to sweep for Nux.
Apparently, I fumbled something here about the first tweet is
golden at least. Oh, I see.
Uh if not for the parents in action,
the children wouldn't be there. Therefore, the children wouldn't
be groomed. You could have said it's the groomer's fault, but
you instantly blame the parents.
Okay. It's a waste of time. I don't argue with re This anime
picture. Do you have any adult characters in your reaction folder?
Why do you keep reacting to you with children? I'm just noticing
a pattern. I'm just noticing a little pattern. I'm not saying
it means anything. I'm just, you know, I'm a noticer by definition.
Just noticing a little pattern. Cute little pattern here.
When someone jokes about you being a nonce, the winning move
isn't to imply you get that often. Oh, classic.
You could have You could have said if someone grooms a child
on Nux Taku's Discord, it's the groomer's fault, not Nux's. But
you totally skipped them to put all the blame on the children's
parents. Why? In case you haven't watched the video, the groomer
in the story was publicly teaching the child how to lie to their
parents in the server's general chat. Okay, so you're you're
explaining this. Let's see if they Do they respond?
I kind of doubt they respond, right? They probably don't respond
back at all.
At the time this was happening, there were only 49 active members
on the server. No moderators, no rules, and Nux Taku advertised
the servers by saying the $1 one-time entry fee is worth it to
meet the person that was grooming the child. Nux Taku still had
them on his podcast twice half a year later. The Patreon wasn't
set to 18+, there was nothing anywhere to claim it's 18+. Nux
just lied. Oh, we got responses here.
One bad thing exists, another thing bad thing exists in tandem.
No, you can't talk Hold on. People do this, right? Oh, I didn't
say anything about Nux's culpability. Yeah, you didn't. That's
the point. The whole video is about Nux doing bad things, letting
bad things happen, and this is one example, and your response
is, "Well, parents should do their job."
Okay, why don't you watch the video?
I I don't know what else to tell you, man. Why don't you watch
the [__] video? Well, it turns out there may have
been a reason
they didn't watch the video, okay?
There could have been a reason, but we have to get further into
it, okay?
I got I think another throwaway comment. This was the next day.
It should be the 18th, 19th, somewhere in there.
20th, okay.
Okay, we're we're continuing through time. I need their video
as well. Give me a second.
and people still mad at me on X. I made a whole baseless.
I gained like 2,500
followers. Dude, I will say Nux appears to have like a real community
with real people. I think I talked about this. I went and I was
just like laughing. I was like, "You should watch the Nicandros
video, man." And a bunch of people in his chat not only knew
about the video and told me to [__] off, but they
knew who I was.
They actually knew things about me.
They knew that I'd covered it. They knew I'd covered the Teccy
stuff.
And I'm like, "Wait, these aren't like
these aren't NPCs? These aren't like bots? I I would have thought
Nux didn't have real engagement." No, he appears to have real
sincere engagement and real people like gifting him subs and
I I just kind of assumed that a lot of this like with the Teccy
people engage with the Teccy people, they're not very smart.
They don't really talk back. And then the Nux people talked back
like they had
It [__] terrified me. I was like, "Oh, [__]
This is a real person. There are real people who watch this guy."
It's It was It was so cool. I don't I don't have an opinion on
the video cuz I haven't seen it. People were like, "How do you
feel about Teccy Tone
and Groom Taku?" And I'm like, "Bro, I don't really care. [laughter]
I don't know about it. I'm going to wait because I you know the
reason why is because every time this happens they're like oh
this person's a All you have to do is not respond.
Or respond I haven't looked into it. Don't give opinions, don't
give dismissals, don't give characterizations, don't give defenses,
don't give anything.
Say I haven't watched or say nothing.
You could even you could even try to give some conditional response.
But dude, just don't don't say you didn't watch and then act
like everybody's crazy for expecting you to watch when you're
clearly associated with these people. We saw them all in your
video, your stupid music video. Saw all those
>> that person's a groomer, that person's a pedo. I'm going
to wait a couple weeks, I'm going to see what happens and then
you know maybe I'll maybe someone will tell me about it and then
like I'll I'll look into it that way, right? Nux finds the yearly
cancel campaign. Yeah, well the thing is is like I'm skeptical
of any cancel campaigns because you want to know why? Because
I know these lefters are liars.
They're dirty liars, little dirty
is bad. It's just a different version of Hassan is bad, isn't
it? These lefters are liars, Hassan is bad. Dirty rat liars.
So I I I just like they've cried wolf so much I just don't even
believe them anymore. I looked into the Technoblade thing slightly.
It's actually so Do you want to know what their logic is? They
put a protective order against against him in civil court. That's
it. Civil court. It's not even a criminal charge and people are
saying like oh he so he oh see see see he raped her. Like what?
[laughter]
It's not even that's that's not even
It's not proof, it's evidence.
And you have to you have to actually use your brain to construct
why people might think Technoblade looks suspicious, right? Technoblade
said he had bulletproof evidence proving he didn't do anything
like she said. He produced none of that evidence and you can
maybe argue he shouldn't produce any of that evidence online.
Maybe he said he was going to produce evidence and his lawyer
said, "Don't do that. Let's save it for court." Then we got to
the court case. He produced no evidence again. Despite saying
he had evidence totally exonerating himself.
Right? And then she had evidence evidence contemporaneous evidence
not proof but contemporaneous evidence that her lip filler got
up at the same time Takedown was talking about [__]
it up and it corresponds precisely to the allegation that she
described. Right? To the assault she described. Now, is that
proof? Could we lock him up? No.
But again, I will ask you, why did Takedown lie about having
exonerating evidence? Why did he not produce it for the court?
If he had exonerating evidence, why did he not produce it?
It it boggles the mind. Guilty until proven innocent.
Actually, now that I'm thinking, did it What did he tell Shamu
about the the exonerating evidence? Did he say, "I can't talk
about it because I have legal things going on?" Well, this was
the legal thing that he was saving it for, right? This is legal
proceedings that he is saving that evidence for.
Why is he Is he going to hold this He's holding it for the next
case, actually. He's holding his exonerating evidence, okay?
Yeah, any Dota fans in the in the chat? You guys ever hear about,
you know, Team Secret saving strats for the next TI? It's the
same thing. Takedown's saving his defenses. He's saving all of
his exculpatory exonerating evidence for the next case, apparently.
Basically, that's what everyone's doing. It's it's stupid. It's
Even if we were to ignore all of the suspicious stuff around
it, like the judge like the judge being biased in like a
It's so transparent, man. It's just
Apparently, the judge was pretty biased, too. Based on what?
Bro, people like, "Oh, the judge was biased cuz she she once
like what was she advocate for like assault victim victims or
she was assaulted and so she can't make a decision. And she That's
why she went so hard." It's like, "No, Takedown describing his
schizophrenia is why she had to go hard on him, okay?
went insane for that for that testimony, okay? The way he described
his schizophrenia not being treated, that he was basing his his
his understanding of the severity of his own diagnosis, which
wasn't a real diagnosis, based on a
You know, and it's this is in Austin, by the way. Like, even
if you were to
>> Yeah, okay. >> Just ignore all of that, right?
And say, "Okay, the judge was totally legit, and there's like,
you know, there's there's no like ulterior motives from anybody."
Even then,
it's not even a criminal charge. You can sue people and get protective
orders for against people for anything. I used to work with with
court cases.
He didn't get a protective order for anything, though. He got
a protective order for reasonable likelihood, or I think it's
reasonable grounds to suspect that he assaulted and stalked her.
He didn't get it for anything, he got it on two things. >> Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Like, a lot. But, I mean, you you know how you know
how civil has a has a much less standard of evidence, basically.
Yep. And it it So, like,
The funny thing is, they could have an argument here. You could
make an argument because it's not even preponderance of evidence
for this, which they're all going to say cuz LegalMindset said
it and they're incapable of individualistic like coherent thought.
They just can repeat what somebody else has told them to say,
so they're going to probably talk about preponderance of evidence.
When in fact, it is a reasonably a reasonable likelihood, or
reasonably likely to have occurred. That's like a lower standard
of evidence again. It's not even preponderance of evidence. So,
actually, they have like a better argument than they even know.
They're too [__] stupid to know. >> even mean
anything. It means that they thought that that there was a possibility
that like that that there's a possibility that he could have
done it, basically.
So, like, they wanted they wanted to err on the side to protect
the the the girl, just in case. >> Something like that.
All it means is that there was a ruling deciding that keeping
them separated was the safest
Nope, that's not true. That's a lie. The ruling was not keeping
them separated as the best. That wasn't it. They would never
grant a 10-year protective order on that basis. That would be
insane.
That would be totally insane.
That's totally made up. That's crazy.
Okay. Anyway, I guess sweeping for Tekton in here as well. This
is supposed to be a part of a whole Tekton sweeping video he's
going to do or like a stream I was going to do. So, some of these
tweets might not correspond perfectly.
Here's this Go Doe guy, Go Doe, coming back again.
Another one.
Okay, another comment. I think I want to go to all the way to
the top of this, They're all faking gay. Universal suffrage was
Does this go up to Yeah, it goes it's all the way down to the
Kadra's thread. Okay.
Person is talking about why they haven't watched the video. They're
just being disingenuous as usual. All the people who are responding.
It's probably dumb because I've seen the same pattern time and
time again of baseless accusations when it comes to content creator
drama. I never and I never will out of spite. Cool. I'm willing
to take the risk of being associated with the groomer simply
because I hate the people making the accusations. Not only is
Not only is this a morally bankrupt position, but you're also
potentially shooting yourself in the foot. You're a
Wow. I have this guy blocked for some reason. I don't know why.
I don't know
But apparently, they're pretty smart.
Fantastic point, right? You're willing to risk it yourself. Now,
it turns out that there's a reason
Why not? Why not? There's a reason
they're willing to risk this, okay? I don't want to I don't want
to get too heavy into the foreshadowing, but there's a reason
they'll risk this, all
We had another guy hopping into the replies real quick.
>> 90% of society's problems can be solved by parents doing
their job and actually raising their kids. Very wise words.
Very wise words. Sadly, most of society now has to suffer immense
censorship and restrictions of freedoms because parents are lazy
and refuse to do their job.
Wow. Wow. Wow.
Okay, so Nikondros,
I finally addressed it. Response shows zero frames in the video
that is supposedly being addressed. This person has immense career
incentives to debunk my criticisms and exonerate NuxTaku, but
I cooked him so good that they can only whine about tweets.
Just want to quickly point out point this out to any other Asmongold
orbiters watching. When your king said this, it was an order
directly to you. Holy Make your Discords 18+ only. Don't let
minors in. It's a total liability. I'm losing all my top guys.
Please remember this
all, but uh Stop letting the kids in your Discord. It has nothing
to do with minors being what the Jesus Christ. People like honestly,
like guys, I'm going to be real. Like if you're a content creator,
you need to stop interacting with anybody that's under 18. You
do. You need to stop doing it. It's a massive mistake. You are
putting yourself in a bad situation.
Stop like do not let the kids do not let them on your Discord.
Don't let them in your community. Don't do anything. Yeah, it's
a total liability. And if you're not a content creator, I mean
listen, everybody now
This is February 14th, okay? This is where you're actually wrong,
Nikondros. You need this tweet to contextualize,
>> knows that it's not a big deal. It's not a problem if
you talk to somebody that's 16 whenever you're playing a video
game, you know, in
Stop letting kids in your Discord servers. It's [__]
over. And then, as if Oh, wow. A VTuber is actually going >> As
if gifted by the gods, three days ago, okay, about a week and
a half later after Asmongold said that, we have this this video
from Harmful Opinions, the first one of three.
Leafy's degenerate Discord server. You can't make it up. You
can't make it up. You actually
can't make it up, okay?
Guys, stop making Discord. And it turned out that Leafy had already
stepped in the [__] bear trap. >> a look at
that Nux Taku video. Oh, she didn't look at it at all. And even
just yapping around it and dodging anything where she'd have
to think or have any sort of spine, she still managed to disappoint
me. Leafy is one of those supposedly religious people who pretends
to be a cartoon on the internet and has all the fire in the world
to spit at every other thing she looks at. Clearly understands
how filth rots its surroundings and radiates outwards, affecting
us all. But on the matter of the corruption of the next generations
online, is fixated on the culpability of the parents, ignoring
entirely that what she's looking at is the next wave of parents
who aren't going to look after their kids and in fact will think
all of what happens in the dark corners of Discord is fine. These
are the people who are going to be the adults your kids are around
in real life. "Where are the parents?" she asks. Where the parents
Where they at? She knows where, though. A huge chunk of her content
is talking about that. All these influencers in the world didn't
show up 5 years ago. The negligent or messed up parent of today
was the kid being corrupted yesterday. It's a vicious cycle that
needs to be broken somewhere unless you're just okay with living
in hell. I find that saying "Not my fault, tee hee." is little
comfort as the world collapses around you. Let's be fair, though.
People wanting you to address stuff that has nothing to do with
you is probably stressful. I could hear the tension in Leafy's
voice. She sounded like a 3-year-old with a severe temporomandibular
deformity for the entire video. But I'm not personally aware
of any tangible connection she has to the Nux stuff. So I get
it, kind of
I love that he's he's so kind, he's so charitable. I think I
think that you sounding is because of the stress. What a nice
job. >> People are pressing you to comment on something
like that. So instead, to make it more relatable and comfortable,
let me give her something of her own to address. But first, imagine
this. There is a community hall, a space where people can gather
and talk about a bunch of different things at a bunch of different
tables. It's not necessarily
targeted at kids, but kids 13 and up are explicitly welcome,
and they do hang out there. Now at the back of this hall, there
is a walled-off area. That's where the theater is, and the adults
who are hanging out in the mixed space pop in and out of there
to together. So it's not just kids and adults hanging out, it's
kids and adults who are there specifically to look at porn hanging
out. Now that seems totally insane to me, but this actually outlines
how many Discord servers are run and how Leafy's own is run.
People have all sorts of arguments and hypotheticals about why
that's fine, why it's safe, why it's a good idea, why it's okay.
Personally, I prefer reality, so let's look at what actually
happens when a server is arranged like this. Let's see what actually
happens in Leafy's server. Meet Ner. Ner is an active user on
Leafy's Discord, who is granted the adults tag. This is acquired
by contacting mods and gives you access to the adults channel.
While the split between the mixed-age areas and the adult channel
is razor sharp and based on some kind of verification, I don't
know what they do, the behavior of the users who pass between
these two spaces isn't quite so night and day. In the Blue Archive
game channel that is open to everyone, early last year Ner posted
a picture of some character or other and said, "Uwo." If you're
not familiar, this is a thing. Another post from Ner should explain
it. They say, "I'm a simple man, I see I uwo." Crying a Wait,
what is what is mean? I don't even know what is this word. Ner
and this person talks about a lot on the server. If you don't
understand what that means, I'll put it in the context of one
of their conversations. This predisposes us to prefer different
ages. Exceptions exist, obviously. Shortly after they say, "Hag
love is unnatural. Embrace I'll hop back to that Blue Archive
channel post. Someone responds to ask, "How old is she?" Ner
says, "Your honor, she told me she was old enough." The other
user responds, "All right, since I'm 13,
I'm maybe good for now anyway. Sam." Ner says, "Damn." Bro just
admitted to being [clears throat] a toddler. At least I'm honest.
That's a good thing. I'm going to go ahead and say that interactions
like this shouldn't be happening. But, as I said earlier, we're
going to be very fair. Maybe Leafy or her mods would agree. Maybe
they just didn't see it. So, let's look at something mods did
see multiple times. Meet Black. On the 24th of September, 2025,
Black posted a couple of screenshots and said, "Help." In these
screen caps, which I think are from VR Chat or something similar,
someone had added him and asked his age. He had told them he's
14. A user in Leafy's chat makes a good suggestion. "What if
she's my age?" You don't want to see my username for meta or
the newer messages, by the way. Another user says, "Women don't
talk to men online. It's a bot or a man." Black says, "Cap."
The good advice user says, "No one normal is going to chat with
you with that username." She's correct about that. The fact that
she didn't know is a major red flag. Also, are you actually 14?
If so, you need to be very careful online. True. There's discussion
on how to be safe and how using Discord that young is a bad idea.
Black complains about how he's treated just cuz he's a kid. And
finally, the mods are pinged. P Dog says, "@moderators, underage
user." The mod Crazy responds, "Okay, we'll make sure to not
give them the role for the channel. It is not against the rules
to be under 18 here. Just don't be a or tylenol user." Geo says,
"Crazy is my favorite mod." P Dog posts a meme. And another mod
called Ducker Bird says, "Also, don't get groomed, kid. Discord
is a dangerous place." Now, there's There's I didn't show you.
Did you catch that? First, though, let me explain something.
I'm censoring Black's name because they claimed to have been
14 and currently they would be 15. And that's normally as far
as people think about it. But they might also actually be an
adult pretending to be a minor talking like this. And what would
that mean? You don't mess around when stuff like this is happening.
You pay attention. Unless you're a
Hey, any other kids in here want to talk? Any other kids in here
getting discriminated against? Hey, any other kids in here having
like a great old time being kids in here? Like kids? They're
just totally kids having a great time cuz they're kids and like
kids and totally kids and 100% definitely not
Any other little kids? Hello? Okay, with a kid making themselves
a target or a predator operating on your server, depending on
whether they're telling the truth or lying. Now, what I didn't
show you were the two pictures he posted. In the first, you just
see the person making contact with him in whatever this is. In
the second image, though, three things jump out immediately.
You've got him telling the stranger he's 14. You can see, though,
that the messages are scrolled up a bit. In the top left, you
can see that the latest message he sent this person was, "Can
I see your My opinion, whether he's telling the truth about his
age or not,
at this point, axe the guy. Get rid of him. Mods have been pinged
into a highly suspect conversation. Surely they looked at these
pictures. But it gets much worse. On the right-hand side of this
second image, Black's Discord is open. Whoever he's messaging
says, "Hi." He says, "What's up?" They say, "Not much. Just chilling.
My headache better." He says, "Dubs, would you show thighs? You
are 17, right?"
>> Right? Solicitation of lewd pictures from someone he
believes to be under 18. Whether Black is actually 14 or an adult
pretending to be 14,
no. A couple months later, mods are once again alerted to Black's
behavior. He constantly talks about some things and his thirst
for fanboys and it annoys the other users. Shawn says to him,
"Seriously, man, stop trying to force your gay fanboy shiz onto
everyone else to avoid accepting that you are gay." Black responds
to an earlier post and says, "My dude, I'm 15." Yagami VT says,
"Mods." in all caps. Floating Cheese says, "Mods." Jackie The
Frost says, "Mods." Holy Danderey actually tags them and so does
Yagami. Jackie The Frost says, "Underage user." Black says, "It's
not legal." Julio shows up confused. Yagami says, "It's against
the rules of the Discord, MF." Julio says, "It's not against
the rules." Julio, by the way, is not just a mod. He is Leafy's
producer. You can see that on his LinkedIn. And also, here's
a clip of Leafy. On YouTube, I'm not even the head decision maker.
I have a producer handling that. His name is Julio.
>> They have a giggle about it and editor seems more accurate.
But, who am I to argue with the guy's CV? None163 says to Black,
"15 and you want to F dudes? You're chopped, cooked, and boiled,
my guy." Black responds, "I already said I'm 15, broski." Holy
Danderey says, "This server is 18 plus, dingus." Black says,
"Cap." Julio asks where it says that. Floating Cheese says, "15
and already gay and addicted." Now, Julio is correct and the
presence of minors is referred to in the rules. In a very strange
rule, rule six. "Act like responsible adults. Even if you may
not be 18, know that this is treated as an adult server."
>> Dude, what are these people
I swear to god.
I think like my Discord situation is sometimes and then I hear
about some of these other people, it's like, "Dude, what?" How
did you write that that rule and think it sounded okay?
absolutely nuts. Also,
also, I forgot
that we have the clip. Somebody get me the clip and just a tweet
if you can of Piers Morgan asking Lauren Boebert what inflation
is. I need We need to watch that before we move on. It'll be
a pal cleaner for you. >> interpret that. Here's how Black
interprets it. It says you can be a minor, but act like adult.
That certainly is what he's doing. Mods are fully aware he's
not being stopped.
Okay, your life could be a lot easier if you just nuked kids
on site and kept a damper on pervert stuff. So, if they do get
in, it's not going to Wow, who would have said that? I wonder
who would have said something like that. It's almost like >> People like
honestly, like guys, I'm going to be real. Like if you're a content
creator, you need to stop interacting with anybody that's under
18. You
Wow. Wow. It'll be the end of the world. Easy for me to say though,
because I'm not a addicted queer who enjoys hanging out and sharing
spank bank material with others. So, I suppose I need to check
my privilege though. I'm not Christian like them. I don't have
a Bible study channel. So, I guess in my faithless state, I'm
just blind to the need for this. Now, Black will be reported
to mods one more time. And this third time, a lot of very, very
strange stuff occurs. I've got like 50 screen caps. I'm going
to show the whole situation, but I'm not going to read everything.
Hello femboy trans Indian, says Black. >> Oh, hey look,
it's Nerf from earlier. Empreg reaction. Nits says not trans
and light version. Black asks them, "Thigh highs?" Cuz I report
them. Tags mods and says, "Minor acting like a horndog in general
chat." Black calls them a snitch. There's a bunch of continued
chitchat. Black says goodbye, but he doesn't leave. Finally,
Julio leaflets mod and a It dude is spamming this Mari Mari like
VTuber at the same time. >> Employee shows up. I have a
ping here, he says. Black says, "I admit I admit I am the wrongdoer.
Time me out, mod. I must learn." Julio says, "Hmm." Julio makes
a poll asking, "Ban the minor, yes or no?" And says, "Your fate
will be decided by chat." Other users support it. Black says,
"A ban is too harsh, so perhaps a warn." Dave Boy shows a picture
of Black talking about his and age. Black says, "If it's necessary,
then goodbye, people." Julio says, "I accept PayPal to change
your ban to time out." I have seen fans of Leafy say that this
was an obvious joke. However, Julio has in fact accepted money
to do things on the server using his mod powers before. For instance,
he accepted five bucks over PayPal to give someone else a name
change. His PayPal link is not exactly hidden, so what would
the punchline of that joke have been? Getting paid by this person
who says they're a kid and is behaving like that to let them
stay? I don't get the joke and I don't find it very funny. Black
I guess ripping them off could be the other side of it, right?
>> Like given that he's never timed them out for this before,
I'm guessing it's not not I guess it's not um you know, just
ripping them off. >> I have Julio says, "We all know you
steal your single mother's card for Robux." Black says, "Very
well." Julio then offers for anyone to PayPal him 20 to stay.
Leafy's employee is trying to sell the server continued access
to someone who says they're a kid and  acts like a horn
dog. This is one of the most insane things I have ever seen on
Discord. You know, if you think about it, it's really the parents'
fault that my producer is auctioning children in my Discord.
Then Black ends up saying, "Goodbye now. I will send myself out."
Julio responds, "Go on, do it then." The users continue to chit-chat
about this and that until eventually they talk about Black again.
The 15th Water says, "Hello everyone, how are you all doing?"
Dave Boy says they kicked out a minor, so fantastic. Well, rather
he surrendered. The 15th Water says, "Yeah, I know. He won't
get out of my DMs." Dave Boy says,  "Why?" asks
Sordo. 15th Water
responds, "He keeps saying sus things about me despite me not
being a minor." Uh what? Did he need $20? asks Dave Boy. Kiss
of Envy says, "The block button is OP." 15th Watcher says, "He's
a simp and keeps wanting me to send thigh pics." Dear viewer,
please remember this. Sounds like you should have blocked him
a while ago. WTF is his issue? In response to the block button
suggestion, the 15th Watcher says, "I feel too bad for him."
As before with this person,
uh what? Dave responds quizzically. Kiss says, "He's a minor
though, no point in talking to him." The 15th Watcher says, "He
is so desperate."
Dude, what?
What? Like, I I feel like I do not negotiate with horny little
boys that want femboy thigh pics.
Dude, I Kiss says, "He needs to find friends his own age, not
adults on the internet." Dave Boy says, "Do not negotiate with
horny little boys that want femboy thigh pics." 15th Watcher
says, "Good point." Guess they just never really thought about
this. It's It's really is complex, isn't it? They briefly discuss
how Black was doxxing himself to them. I don't know if that's
true or not, and I don't trust these people to be able to check.
Dave Boy says, "Do not brain the youth. You made the right call."
And the next message is from Julio, the mod, Leafy's employee,
the one called the producer who seems to be an editor. Given
the conversation he's been watching, what do you think he says?
Take a guess. 3 2 1 Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait Wait, wait, wait, wait, I
got to say something. And the Dave Boy says, "Do not porn brain
the youth. You made the right call." And the next message is
from Julio, the mod, Leafy's employee, the one called the producer
who seems to be an editor. Given the conversation he's been watching,
what do you think he says?
What would be the appropriate thing? Stop talking about this
in here. Stop Stop yanking this person first.
Uh if you talk about this in here again, I will ban you. Would
be the appropriate thing. Like, you can't talk to this person.
Stop doing it. If he
If he does something like suggest that they continue communicating
and stuff the minor
don't know what's going to happen. >> Take a guess. 3 2
>> Please don't. Please don't. Please don't. But, that's
my guess. But, that's my guess. He's going to make some joke
about the minor further. Uh, right. Right. Definitely, cuz he's
a total >> He has not been banned yet. The other users
had to continue to work to convince him to finally ban Black.
I see. Well, same difference, really. >> it's over. Except
for one thing. Do you remember that person who said, "Oh, they
didn't want to block him cuz he's so desperate." He's constantly
trying to rizz them, begging for thigh pics. After what appears
to be the moment of the actual ban finally happening, that person
goes on to talk about how he's constantly trying to date them.
They know he's constantly trying to flirt with the donks. By
the way, this idea that, "Oh, if two people say they're underage,
doing that stuff together is fine." No, that's exactly how happens.
That's how predators get their victims. Besides the point though,
if Black is the age they say they are, which this person certainly
believes, something I think is pretty damn bad has occurred.
23 minutes after the actual ban, the 15th watcher says, "I already
have dread thinking about my past interactions with him. I sent
him a fully covered and clothed thigh picture once to get him
to shut up. I fear it made it much, much worse. I never imagined
I'd find myself saying this, but apparently it needs to be stated.
If someone on the internet claiming to be a child is pursuing
you do not send them pictures of your thighs, clothed or not.
And the people observing this, including Julio, Leafy's mod and
employee, apparent editor, producer, so on. This is just normal
to you people? I think, um, I think the depravity is too far,
chat. I think it's I think it's gone too far. I think, uh, this
is It's all so performative, right? All the time. It's all It's
just But now I feel like you're starting to get the idea of why
they maybe weren't making such a big deal out of minors in the
Discord
You know what I'm saying? You know what I'm saying? I guess I'm
starting to see why maybe they didn't make such a big deal. Why
it would have been profitable for them to not really care as
much about minors in Discord. Now, Leafy's Discord mods respond.
Apparently, there's a response too. >> Yesterday, I uploaded
a video which, amongst other things, pointed out an individual
in Leafy's server who, just a couple months ago, was talking
about how another user who claimed to be 15 was trying to rizz
them up, begging to date him, begging for pictures, so on and
so forth. A mod and employee called Julio was clearly reading
this conversation and stepped in to say that the guy saying he's
15 has not been banned, only banning him later under more pressure
from the users. A little while later, the user who said this
person who claims to be 15 was pursuing them explained that they
once sent him a picture of their thigh, fully clothed, to get
him to shut up. And I suggested that this is totally insane,
clothed or not. In Leafy's community, this appears to be the
main thing that was picked up on. And people demanded action.
A mod who goes by PreCure in Leafy's Discord actually took it
very seriously. They even went as far as calling it grooming.
Here is what Leafy's mod had to say about the 15th watcher, the
person who sent the photo. 15th is the one getting groomed here,
bros. And posts evidence in the form of the person who claimed
to be 15 saying, "Want to go out? I have super good rizz." Perhaps
that's irresistible to people like you. Oh, >> "Want to
go out? I have super good rizz." Perhaps that's irresistible
to people like you. I would simply not send the child a picture
of myself of any kind. Prior to that, PreCure was complaining
about my video, calling it bad faith, and complain
I can't be the only person who like just
Like maybe I'm trying to think when I was like 18, 19, would
I have been like, "Oh, you're 17, don't talk to me." Probably
not, right?
But like I'm old now, okay? I'm 30. I'm old as [__]
for the internet, all right? Bro, I've never I can't imagine
what a What would you even get out of these conversations unless
like No offense.
Minors are [__]
There There aren't intelligent minors. YOU'RE NOT GETTING CONVERSATION
OUT OF THEM. They're not getting conversation. You're getting
something else. There's like one acceptable case to be doing
stuff with minors on the internet as somebody who like doesn't
know them, has no relationship to them, and only met them online,
and that's playing video games. That they're in like your matchmaking.
They Maybe they're somebody you played with in matchmaking. You
like playing with them, and you add them, and you play. Dude,
if you found out that your like buddy you were queuing with in
like Rivals or something was actually a minor, I feel like there's
no way you would want to go to Discord and extend that relationship.
that relationship.
Right? So, I just I don't understand how this even Like there's
to me Basically, when this stuff happens with minors, there's
like almost no pretext. Like there's no There's no like justifiable
relationship that people could have
that makes it make sense to me that these people will like DM
with minors off of these servers.
It makes no [__] sense to me.
>> Finding out that they have a hot single >> Finding
out that it doesn't give them a clear idea of anything wrong
happening, and they in fact have counter evidence that I suppose
they're upset I didn't include. You see, they have evidence that
the child was asking for it very aggressively. SOMEONE ASKED
PRE-CUM
>> PLEASE STOP. PLEASE STOP. >> WHAT THEY'RE trying
to prove.
Dude. Uh
Every Every single weeb in an Asmongold adjacent community is
just Roman Polanski to them. They'll die on every hill, okay?
It's like a random Discord chatter, okay? Oof. And they explain
that they're proving it's a 15-year-old taking advantage of that
person. There's no power imbalance because they're both I was
told this was a based VTuber community, but that is literally
the wokest thing I have ever heard in my life. Garth asks, "Where's
the controversy?" Precure says, "They're trying to get us to
ban the who got groomed by the minor in
Hold on, cuz I've made this argument once before, okay? But in
that in that case, you could see that that's what it was, okay?
And by the way, the person still has to be punished, unfortunately.
I think it was
It was the
not Hatofull boyfriend. It was the Yandere's Yandere Dev Simulator,
whatever, the Yandere Dev guy, okay? Yandere Simulator, that
guy? That guy was totally groomed by minors. I'm sorry, that
guy was like
and that guy was like he just wanted anybody to talk to him.
That is the one case, and the minors By the way, the minors were
like in a group and laughing about how humiliating how how much
this guy was humiliating himself, okay? That guy was groomed
by minors. I'm sorry, they were like high schoolers or some [__]
I I will die on that hill. That is the only case I've ever seen
that's not this case, okay? That's not this case. That one was
like the minors literally did have the power in that situation
in a way, and you still would punish the guy with he I think
he basically got
But it's like I can see in that situation that they were all
like baiting this guy into saying things that he would eventually
get baited into, and then they'd record it and they'd make fun
of it in group chats. I think that's very different, though,
okay?
In response to the earlier post about there being no power imbalance,
Kiss of Envy says, "Forget the power imbalance." Yeah, obviously
he's a weirdo. Yeah, obviously he shouldn't be around kids at
>> Once then, the fact a legal adult is sending any sort
of provocative pics to a minor is a problem. Precure responds,
"I mean, he's 15. It's not like he's grooming an 8-year-old."
Julio said,
Honestly, at this point, like for me, you got to ban these people,
too. Anybody who's willing to go, "Dude, he was just grooming
a 15-year-old. It's not like It's not like he was eight. It's
not like the person was eight that was getting groomed." Bro,
you got to go. You actually have to go. You cannot You You can't
utter that statement and then share space with minors.
That person's got to be gone, okay? As guys stop asking for pictures
of people. Kiss responds, "Even if it's a clothed thigh pic,
it's a liability for an adult to be sending any kind of pics
to minors, honestly. It's a liability to everyone." Julio says,
"I agree, which is why I asked, when did it happen and why he
wasn't banned or at the very least told to stop being stupid."
As I showed at the start Oh, is that Julio guy trying to pretend
he wasn't around for all of this? >> video, it happened
2 months ago and they weren't banned because you were in the
conversation and chose not to do that, Julio. Ultimately, Precure
does ban the weirdo, but not because of any of that, because
of the worst thing, of course, the hypocrisy. I banned him because
he was staunchly an anti-pedo.
>> Oh, it's the normal McDonald clip again. It just always
hits. It always hits just right. This Dude, this person This
person wanted that guy out of the server forever because he was
anti-pedo?
He just got the He just got his his rationale, okay? This Precure
person wanted the anti-pedo guy out of the server. You know,
anti, but also DMing teenagers. You can't be both of those at
the same time unless you're projecting and actually a pedo. So
long as you do that stuff and say it's good, you're clear? What
is wrong with all of these people? I feel like this has been
created to make me lose my mind. The child auction from the last
video had me sitting at my computer unable to move for like 20
seconds, stunlocked. Now, this was a short video, but you know,
when people address things I cover, I should cover that, too,
right? All these based VTubers are like religious communities,
too, right? So, let's end with a religious message. Do you guys
know the story of the flood? That's sort of how I view all the
incoming changes and regulations to the internet and all these
platforms. The digital world has been allowed to fester and rot
entirely, and so what do we get? A digital world ending event.
People like to say this is happening because parents don't do
their job, but I have some bad news. That's actually the first
part of the argument for regulation and restriction. Goes like
this. It's the parents' responsibility.
Yeah, why why do I have to deal with a bunch of like victims
for the rest of my life? We just let all these people get cuz
their parents suck. Turns out parents have always sucked since
time immemorial. Some parents have sucked, okay? I don't have
to I I don't want people who think it's okay to groom kids to
grow up because they got groomed as a kid, okay? I don't want
people to be into grooming cuz they got groomed as a kid and
now they think it's okay. We just do an infinite cycle of grooming
forever and ever and ever and ever. They've abdicated that responsibility.
Therefore, we get to step in, create a vacuum, and it will be
filled. You're not countering them. You're agreeing with them.
We never had much of a chance against it, but the only chance
we did have was to develop a culture of zero tolerance for this
[__] To be able to say, "No, actually you don't need
to replace the role of the parents. The basic duty that every
adult has towards protecting children is enough, just like it
is in real life." It should be Dude, and like here's the thing.
There's a duty to protect kids up until a point. When it costs
you nothing. When it costs you nothing. It is like you you hit
a button that's a setting for some video. It costs you literally
nothing to make sure that parents can protect their kids right
on YouTube. You just hit the 18 plus thing and then you're not
you there's nothing to worry about. And by the way, you can even
be forgiving on that. If NuxTaku done one video that had like
a uh like thumbnail of some kind, and then he realized somebody
had messaged him be like, "Hey, my kids watch your channel."
Right? And then he fixed it.
Uh it's not even Nobody's going to like and kick him off the
internet.
Right? It's the persistent pattern, the persistent targeting
that's frustrating. And you refusing to hit the 18 plus button
cuz it'll affect your your advertising, right? It costs you not
a lot. It costs you a lot Oh, it costs you a lot not to show
them to kids actually. It really doesn't. It really doesn't.
It's like no effort at all actually.
I understand for some of these people it's Herculean.
But that's a different That's a different problem, okay?
be enough to just go after and deter the people who have done
and would do something wrong. That's all we need from you, power.
Thanks. We're not savages. This isn't a hell world. But it is.
But the most basic values have gone out the window. Our culture
in real life is a rotting patchwork and online it's worse. Essentially,
none of this would be happening if people could just simply not
be totally insane. The fault of the parent is negligence. Whether
or not anything happens to their kid, they have done something
wrong if they aren't looking after them. The fault of the person
who does things with or to that kid is what they have done. The
fault of the observer is inaction. It is good to do things about
that which you are able. And not only that, to not do so creates
space. Space for power to creep in. You guys are gamers, right?
How has the games industry historically countered government
intervention? They don't just go, "Oh, parents should be able
to control this. Oh, no. Oh, no. Guess we'll get regulated the
[__] Nothing I could do, dude." It's actually the
fault that they create the ESRB, right? And then they create
their own rating system and then they actually make sure all
games sit within that rating system so that they don't get like
absolutely asked for by What was the guy's name?
Oh, it was like Jack something. It was a long time ago. Bro,
this was like during the Bush administration. You remember the
guy? Thompson, right? Jack Thompson, am I remembering this correctly?
Yeah. Wanted like all violent video games regulated so that you
would have to give up all your Basically, he wanted all these
video games like banned if you had like violence in video games
and [__] He wanted that [__] gone. Or
at least prevented like from any kids prevent any kids from watching
it. And it turns out that was wrong. That kids can play games
with some amount of violence in them and it's actually not that
big a deal. Okay? You pointed out that kids gambling is bad,
right? That would be
Even if you don't personally care, like the games industry certainly
doesn't, you're going to get ramped up the Dude, I I used to
go on a rants about this in university. Like for I would I would
rant and rant cuz I I did like some of this not CSGO but like
Dota gambling stuff with skins and like the idea of the chests
and stuff. It was just obviously gambling and I'm like, "Dude,
why didn't I think of this? Just figure out how to sell vices
to kids." Twitch will do Twitch will sell softcore to kids. Valve
will sell gambling to kids and they'll both make an absolute
So cool. Little did I realize Valve was about the least egregious
in in like 5 to 10 years Valve would be by far the least egregious
example of this. Every mobile game a thousand a trillion times
>> Yes with that strategy and that's the strategy we've
collectively chosen for years and years and years. So guess what
happens to us. You can argue as much as you want that jumping
out a window shouldn't hurt you but eventually
you're going to hit the ground and blaming others will do little
to heal your shattered legs.
Okay, so Leafy did an actual response
Or yesterday maybe but but it looks like Harmful's done another
video, an even longer video on Leafy's Discord. Leafy's pathetic
Disc server Discord server defense.
So now we get an actual response from
take a look. Let's take a >> this one, boys. But I'm sure
someone in the comments will provide a timestamp if you want
to see where I start looking at Leafy's comments. Over and over
in response to my last couple videos and comments and elsewhere,
I see people very upset that I'm blaming Leafy for this stuff
that was done in her Discord. I feel there's been a misunderstanding.
I said Leafy should address it. I didn't say answer for, I didn't
say be punished for. I said it's something I'd like to see her
address, as in give attention to and fix. In my first video,
I showed an example of someone who says they're 14 and 15 repeatedly
talking with other members in a mixed-age Discord, having attention
drawn to them over and over and over again, and being allowed
to remain. When they were finally banned, it was only because
of pressure that was kept up by the people who wanted this kid
gone. And I made the suggestion of simply banning minors. To
quote myself, I said, "Your life could be a lot easier if you
just nuked kids on site." This
this might be true, but I luckily my community's like 18-plus,
like all parts of my community are 18-plus.
Like obviously kids could be watching, but I'd say there's not
like a lot that appeals to kids in my content. It's like a lot
of politics content.
I can't imagine there are a lot of kids who are like, "Yeah,
I'm going to go listen to this penguin talk make an anti-Semitic
joke for the 800th time." You know what I'm saying?
It's just like I I kind of I worked myself out of that genre
pretty quickly.
>> Okay. even actually be a new policy. It would be a rollback.
You can see in 2021 that they used to do this. They used to get
rid of any kids they knew about. So, this is originally an 18-plus
server that at some point they decided to open up to kids. I
don't know when exactly or why, and my obvious suggestion is
to go back to that. I don't think that's too crazy or evil or
unfair at all. People have talked a lot about what I'm trying
to do to Leafy. What I'm trying to do is get her to do something
like that. Listen to what I say in those videos. Doesn't matter
if you can say it's not my fault if what you're doing is letting
everything go to [__] That's my repeated argument.
I think what I'm suggesting is quite clear. Now, many people
in the comments have argued that I can't suggest Leafy do anything
about this because she's not the owner of the server, it's nothing
to do with her. And Leafy can be seen in there saying, "I literally
do not own this server, did you know that?" And she said that
a few times, and in 2025, you can see her saying technically
I totally forgot for all the people whining about my server,
I could just say that. I literally don't even own my Discord
server. BBG Poison does. Thank you, Leafy. I I found a new way
to abnegate all responsibility.
Thank you. Thank you. I also enjoy abnegating responsibility
on my own
Leafy's giving me new tech. I love this. fan server, and many,
many people have told me her server is the Patreon one, and this
is a common source of confusion. The server I've been looking
at is Leafy's official Patreon server. One of my little minions
went to Leafy's Patreon. If you buy into the £8 or the £39 tier,
you will be granted Discord access and Patreon exclusive channel
access. When you use the link the Patreon gives you to get that
Discord access, it is this server. If it's true that she has
no power over it, I think she probably shouldn't be selling people
access to it and access to channels within it. Another
More people point to Leafy saying she Oh, damn it. Harphul just
ruined my
Harphul just ruined my whole [__] cuz I make money
from people who buy for buy like Discord privileges. [__]
the owner, and they say the mods run it. None of the comments
or messages I've read say which one is the owner. Other people
like Gibbs on Twitter and KF have done similar with other tools
as well, but I used a Better Discord plugin called Permissions
Viewer to take a look, and it turns out that the mod who has
the owner role is someone called Asari Mitsua. Leafy fans will
certainly know who this is. For people not familiar, Leafy's
main channel isn't Leafy, it's Leafy and Asari. This is the other
half. This is Leafy's mother. This is who the plugin identifies
as having the owner role. It also identifies Leafy herself as
having admin privileges, and she Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait. So, is it actually her mom or not? >> a unilateral
stand against behavior in her server before. Regarding an uptick
in people saying slurs about trans people, Leafy stepped in to
say, "I'll just say it myself, even though I'm not the owner
of the server. While discourse is allowed and appreciated, please
be It's actually her mom.
Okay, what the [__] are we doing here? Come on, man.
>> welcome civil discussion, but we do not welcome slurs
or direct personal attacks. Discussing cultural or LGBT stuff
is fine, but using it as an opportunity to throw Also, is Leafly
a minor? Cuz Leafly sounds like they're like 25 or 30. How old
is her mom? They've got to be a minor, right? Leafly? or slurs
around instead of facing the cultural argument itself is unacceptable,
even to me. You have the freedom to say these things, but I have
the freedom to not like it and to not allow it in our private
community. And you can Leafly is 40. Leafly is 40.
Honestly, I think that's like really I would almost be envious
of that to have like that connection with your parents that you
could do content together, as long as it's not like connected
to some weird degeneracy. I would almost be envious of that that
they could connect with their parents that way and like do some
[__] Leafly worked for Riot's right in the early
2010s. Oh, interesting. I can't imagine it being over anime stuff.
There's like some part of it where it's like they found her mom's
Pornhub
can say it somewhere else because I want a place where discourse
is based on the content and logic and not on personal insults.
She then even says if people are too off the rails, they'll have
to make more rules. My plea to Leafly is, you also have the freedom
to not allow kids. Your friends, fans, and people who just generally
like you can make all the excuses they want for things that happen
as a result of welcoming minors with open arms and your mods
being flakes. Would it not be better to simply not have to make
excuses at all? Just a keep on site policy when your users beg
you to ban an underage you It's like the opposite of Skyrim,
okay?
Anyone ever play Skyrim and get super pissed you can't get the
kids? In Discord, you you are actually compelled to. It's actually
moral It's your moral duty to kill as many kids as you can in
Just nuke their accounts immediately, okay? User, when they ping
the mods in, they see that the person said it, right click, ban.
Instead of umming and ahing over whether the kid is posting hornily
enough for that to be a problem, just get rid. I can't make you,
but given what I was shown and then what I saw myself, it would
be remiss of me not to suggest it. Hopefully, this clarifies
things. I don't normally like to dumb it down this much, but
it seems necessary in this case. Now, I'm going to cover a couple
other things people have said in response. A lot of people didn't
like that I explained the "uwu" post and what that means. I explained
because I think most people aren't familiar. So, I showed this
person explaining that "uwu" is what they say when they see what
call young characters.
Young or smaller child-like characters. And they say there's
no problem here because there isn't a real child involved. Now,
they could be lying, but they said this multiple times and were
consistent. They said, "All right, since I'm 13, I may be good
for now." Anyway, Zam, I don't think it's good for adults to
be hanging out with 13-year-olds doing this "uwu"
and talking together about the cartoons they think are hot. Do
you think that's fine? How many 13-year-olds do you chill with
in a little chat room and discuss pictures you find with? Wouldn't
it be better if that wasn't happening and a place wasn't set
up for it to happen by welcoming children? But it's not just
the arrangement of the server that causes problems when allowing
children. Your mods are a problem, too. For instance, just brushing
off someone acting the way Black was while claiming to be 14
and then 15. But it goes all the way up to being concerning,
like the mod PreCure, whose address I just found. Just kidding.
PreCure says they like being these video
>> Oh, no. Is Is Harmful getting into Nick Andros' posting?
Dude, I I've I reference it all the time, but there's nothing
funny to me than Nick Andros being like, "Oh, by the way, Mutahar,
I could totally find where you live." And then he like goes into
Photoshop, starts like doing angular masks to like get the the
like front of some building off of Google Maps. He's like, "Look
how easy I can find where you live." So, I'm like, "Holy [__]
what are you doing, man?" >> Here's what I thought. By
the way, I would never use this against you, but I just want
you to know that I could find it very easily. I'd give them a
star card. Did you enjoy that? One of the people I pointed out
in my first video, who I'm glad to have the scalp of, they were
banned, had claimed in the server to have sent a thigh picture
to a minor who had been pursuing them. They said it was to try
to calm them down, and they said it was both, but obviously,
hell no. Right click, ban. Someone says that in your server,
they're gone. You don't need to investigate it beyond confirming
that they were making those claims. PreCure Hunter, the person
who banned them, argued that the adult is the one getting groomed.
I left out context. I wanted to see who would instinctively jump
up to immediately defend this, say it's okay, say it's a joke,
not check themselves, just, you know, in their gut, they feel
like this is fine and needs to be defended. Who is like that?
The answer is Mama Aiko. I kind of feel
>> Mama Aiko, unfortunately, and I I do say unfortunately
cuz I believe they've they've sent me a whole bunch of money.
Mama Aiko, if you hear this, okay?
I need where are you on my overall lifetime kicks.
Where is she here? Oh, she's not even on my lifetime kicks list.
Oh, never mind. I was like, "If you could get up to number one
on my lifetime kicks list, I would consider sweeping for this,
but you're not really all that close." >> You like that's
just another joke right now. You know, I've observed the server
my cuz I've been in the server. I've been like just sitting in
there for months at this point. I never look at it. Is that just
that just feels like another joke, my man? As I show more examples,
Mama Aiko becomes increasingly certain that it's all a big joke,
that the mod was saying this to troll me. They in fact have counter
evidence that I suppose they're upset I didn't include. You see,
they have evidence that the child was asking for it very aggressively.
Someone asks PreCure what they're trying to prove.
Oh my gosh. He is
He is taking this at face value so hard. Oh my gosh. You know,
I'm a
And sometimes
I can't tell when somebody's with me, all right? But I can tell
right there that he is intentionally [__] with him.
Um was it started by you or how does that work? >> I can
I can I can clear it up real quick. Basically, it's it's a server
like it's a fan server for the community. I don't get a vote
in like
Jesus. I don't moderate under any moderation on it. >> Interesting.
12th of the 2nd, 2025. I don't personally get involved unless
it's just an easy ban, says Leafy. I don't normally involve myself
in Discord since I don't run it, but if I catch you using slurs
in a bad faith manner, I will personally send you to the shadow
realm. 30th of the 6th, 2025.
If we if we take bad faith to mean like disingenuously, like
you don't believe it, are you saying that if they're not sincerely
using slurs, you send them to the shadow realm?
>> I want you to mean it when you call that guy the hard
R, okay? If I find out he's white or you're [__]
around, I want you to mean it. And if you don't mean it, you're
out of here. Out. >> Don't post needlessly edgy jokes.
It can get the server in trouble. Fair enough. I do the same
with Twitch chat and stuff. So, I'm going to have to time them
out / remove them, says Leafy. >> Like I don't actually
like do any enforcement action at all. If what I showed was the
last time you were doing it, that's only been true for barely
over half a year. In fact, like the funny thing is is when it
comes to like
like there being younger people on the server, I I said like
just nuke all of them. Like I don't care. Right? I don't care
about >> Oh, I just don't care. Let it happen. Turns out
when Leafy said it's the parents' fault, she was literally talking
about her mother, the mod. This
Grow a spine. You're happy to earn money off of it directly as
your official Patreon server. You should also be happy Honestly,
this is why
I think the only first and only rule I really proposed for my
Discord was just 18 plus. Like I never want to deal with any
of the issues surrounding kids. It like as much as people clown
on Asmongold, it is just an easier way like then it's all consenting
adults and it's who gives a Right? It's like the easiest rule
to just have and it makes moderating Discord super easy. Why
take on any of the burden for having younger people in there?
And then like if you're going to do that, then you have to do
it, right? That's a decision. You've made a decision. If you
want to take If you want to have younger kids, you know, like
anybody under 18 in your Discord, you have made that decision.
That's your decision. You've taken that responsibility on. You've
You've inherited some responsibility for making that decision.
It's an old and insane [__] happen on it. Getting
rid of it actually ditching it is also an option. >> I
don't really have anything to do with like which channels get
added um or or anything like that. Well, three days ago your
mod crazy claimed otherwise. I don't have any control, just the
authority to demand a channel stays and the ability at any time
to revoke your blessing and association. The claim that you can
only make suggestions when you do have the power to force them
doesn't mean anything. Leafy then confirms that her mom owns
it. But did you start it or um people are saying that your mom
actually owns it? The reason my mom owns it is in case that we
have to get we have It's It's to protect from like a crazy mod
Okay, so >> Nothing to do with me.
>> What? What? The reason a mom owns it is cuz it's like
to protect it and like if a crazy uh uh uh
That's It's not a fan server if your mom owns it. It's my mommy.
>> Sorry, how old are you? I'll explain
There's been a lot of drama in the Discord in the past. Uh-huh.
And it's to protect
It's It's so that if she So, my mom doesn't do anything either.
Like, she doesn't do any like moderation or anything like that.
>> Mhm. She doesn't do any moderation? What did your mother
mean 10 days ago when she said, "Ban that guy"? 4 days ago when
she responded to a mod ping that was just a a meme? >> It
only
in case that way we can give the we can give the uh the ownership
to like a different >> Yeah, my mom's the owner. She doesn't
moderate except when she does. And she's only the owner so that
she can make someone else an owner. Hm. But, in case there was
like a crazy in in the it's like a ultimate contingency
of like if the mods go out of control, we can like retake everything
and give it to a different person. So, that makes sense. >> Makes
perfect sense. That's called being the owner of a Discord server.
That's called having the final say. That's called being in charge.
The chat chat and Mama Arco says, "He'd just ban minors, you
know, to avoid problems." Yes, that's my videos.
Um but in all of 2021 2021, I believe Discord's or sorry, Leafy's
account got banned. So, that's why and funny enough, that is
literally why BB Poison has ownership of my server is cuz I'm
at like a really high proclivity to get reported and he has no
reports.
He isn't type a whole lot. He doesn't say like super offensive
[__] all that often. Loves hearing other people say
it, which is probably why he like patronizes this channel. But,
he just doesn't say that much. So, that's literally why I I would
imagine it's something similar where it's like, "I just want
an account that literally doesn't do anything that owns the server."
Cuz when my account got banned, there was a chance that like
somebody who was a mod or a an admin could have like maybe applied.
I think he was the only one though. I think he had the next highest
role in the hierarchy.
But, I just left it with him cuz I'm like, "Well, one, I trust
him. And two,
Yeah, I just I think my account has like a higher proclivity
to get reported or
Yeah, we could have I could have been the disastrous if Taken
had been able to take over. That would have been [__]
up. Correct. That's the point. Leafy explains her service moderation
culture. Ooh, I guess I guess what I would would say is the mod
culture on our server is to we don't ban right away. Like we
have a very like our policy on banning stuff and like you know
you can maybe make the argument that like this should be a case
in which like the person just gets automatically banned, but
our ban we are hesitant to ban people. >> Sorry, we? Anyway,
no, not people. You're hesitant to ban kids. I watched your mods
not exactly be hesitant to holocaust a bunch of people they were
suspicious of. You guys are hesitant about certain bans. Why?
>> Because of um well, it's because of reasons of um people
getting brigaded or like censorship or anything like that. Like
we kind of want people to be able to talk and be more comfortable.
I like to let people talk, too, but what video was Mama Aiko
just watching before you hopped on? What was that about? >> Okay.
So, that might be a maybe that's a bad idea, I don't know, but
>> When it's someone who says they're a kid wilding out,
certainly yes. Leafy says they're getting you know, it's their
culture, it's how it is. Mama Aiko for some indecipherable reason
finds this to be incredibly valuable information. >> See,
what what's what's interesting about that is I feel like people
would have found that out if they had maybe asked. No, I know.
I watched it happen. My video's about that. They do be hesitating.
The people coming to the UK say it's just their culture, too.
They see the button they can't resist tweets for a while and
yap about a bunch of other stuff. They do a whole bunch of Noxtaku
sweeping. It's actually crazy and then they get on to mentioning
my video. Leafy decides to complain about a visual gag. Which
was like the thing about the um I'm banning him because he's
anti like pedo.
Right? And so like they they showed that part of it first to
like seed that in your mind and then showed the context after.
It's called a joke, sweetie. Muselk's Twitch now. Comedy's legal
again. If you show the context, it changes it. Yeah, I showed
the context.
You've successfully explained the joke. If I hadn't, sure that
would be a problem, but I love how that is treated like some
kind of Israeli psyop. Well, Nux Taku EPI'ing hundreds of thousands
of kids is just, you know, whatever. It's me who's seeding things
in people's minds. Leafy then tries to argue that what PreCure
said was a joke.
They're They're a lot of them are like that. And it's kind of
like the [__] out of here, man. He's trying to make
a point that if you're like like I'm Yeah, he's making a a joke.
He's probably projecting. So, he probably is actually
a you know, a PDF, right? And then that that that was the whole
joke. >> Unfortunately, Leafy Lent, PreCure has already
addressed this, and it was not a joke. Nine, who was being silly
and just showed the start of the gag, asked, "What did you mean
by this?" The mod explains their whole statement. Basically,
if he was super pro-pedophile anti-ped, then I knew he had grooming
on the mind and wouldn't make that mistake, honestly. Presumably
referring to sending the picture. If he had never mentioned lollies
or anything like that, and he was then it's plausible that he
could have made that mistake. PreCure justifies spending time
to seriously think about this. The drama was basically a necro
post, and the kid had already been banned ages ago, so it's not
like it was time sensitive, and I just wanted to be thorough
with my options. And one of the most obvious and basic things
to do whenever you are in a he-said-she-said
Oh my god, he-said-she-said scenario is to at least give each
side the benefit of the doubt.
The tipsy MTF voice is like Chad for the Chad. Wait, what?
I don't know what you mean. I I do get the feeling that like
there's something about
either the like MTF
like recently voice trained voice or the like husky
pre-diabetic voice female voice that conservatives just go nuts
for, and I don't know what it is.
I really don't. I don't know what it is. >> I understand
how many statements could be taken as just a joke. Not seeing
it in this one. This is the mod of a server that welcomes children
giving benefit of the doubt to someone who claimed they sent
an image of themself to a minor who was pursuing them Mama Alko
further defends it by saying it's a Harmful. Why Why do you have
to act like me when I don't understand a joke? Bro, it's it's
very obvious
Well, I don't know I don't know Mama Alko's politics or whatever.
I don't know. But with a lot of these people they're running
with the Azm and Gold Um they're all these perverts and degenerates
who are ruining everything for everybody. Right? Oh, and uh there's
a not no small amount
of like religious reawakenings or religious awakenings amongst
these people, too. Right? They're like anti-degeneracy degenerates.
It's
so bizarre. It's so bizarre.
I don't know why I don't know Like I could even understand why
that would be an attractive genre for people. Oh, these people
are like you know, there's this group of right-wing influencers
who don't like how the internet was degenerate and they have
moved away from that and all of this [__] But then
why are you sweeping for someone grooming kids in your Discord?
Or why are you sweeping for any of this? Why? It's like not So
yeah, there's degeneracy in conservatism. Sure, but it's not
this kind of degeneracy.
Unless it's at pageants. Yes, that this man is saying right now.
Leafly elaborates and says that pre-cure statements are old internet
humor. Yeah, we I mean we just have a lot of like stupid humor.
It's like kind of old internet people. No, yeah. Old internet
folk and we A little bit later they talk about what they think
me and people like me are. Like these are like these people are
modern day journalists.
It's not really like that surprising. Well, they definitely They're
definitely They definitely try.
Modern day journalists. Does that not say everything about where
America is, to be honest with you? Like that's what their opinion
is of journalists? He just used journalists as a slur. These
people are like modern day journalists. It's like
You know, when they reach a certain bar like some of the Nikocado
stuff
I kind of almost agree. Modern day journalists not that far off.
But they're using it as a literal slur.
They're like, like modern-day journalists.
Modern-day journalists.
to imply a lot of things and do a lot of these things
to try and paint a narrative and I'm being quite direct. I think
that server is an inappropriate environment to welcome children
into and Leafy's mods are inept. Maybe if you clear house and
get better people to run the server, you could keep having kids
in there. I wouldn't recommend it though. If you keep these people
in charge though, No, those are like independent investigative
journalists. You're like a
You're like a leftist journalist who insists these people like
not kids and it's just it's really weird, okay? You're a weirdo.
How do you even find God without Dude, never mind.
>> It's like finding God through Connie is like these people's
motto and it is disturbing on so many levels to me, okay? They're
You definitely need a policy on mods on site. I mean, even PreCure
thinks that's obvious. A little bit later, Leafy and Mom Arko
suggest I should have tried to interview everyone involved.
I I just don't understand that. Like like again, when I when
I covered
I'll just like say my own Cinder video. I didn't tell anybody
this, but before I started working on the first Cinder video,
I DM'd almost every single person involved and asked them if
they wanted to talk about it. Nobody ever got back to me, sadly.
But like if I had the ability to say, "Hey Shy Lily, can you
answer questions about this?" Or "Hey Bow, I understand you're
hurt about this, but can you talk about this?" And if they
I think you should always do this. I know Nux I know Nick Landers
didn't do this for Nux. I think you should always do this
because there is always a chance they're going to say something
that trips them and makes your story.
If for no other reason than that.
Assuming there is no reason to hide what you're trying to show,
I think with Nick Andros, I think Nick Andros wanted some of
the links to still be live when he published the video, so that
people could check for themselves on certain things, right? I
think that was something he wanted, so warning Nux by asking
questions that you might have actually slowed things down. I
would have done it. Yeah, yeah. I don't care how bad it would
have made Slander look. I would have done it because I wanted
to get it right.
Well, you're trying to find the truth, right? Like That's my
goal, yeah. Yeah. Interview is indeed a tool one can use. My
coverage is of what occurred in the Discord server and whether
that's acceptable or not. Interviews in this case would be of
no value to me and would have no bearing on what I observed.
This is like a toddler's understanding of journalism. Not that
I would consider what I'm doing to be journalism. If you're concerned
about right to reply, the owner of the server I've commented
on has access to a massive platform and I am currently presenting
your response where my claims were made. If you want to actually
discuss journalism, we can talk about
I think right to reply for people of relatively equal platform
sizes,
uh even dispro disproportionate platform sizes. So long as you
both have a public public platform,
I think so long as you're willing to engage with their response,
you're giving them a right of reply, right?
Like if Nux sorry, if not Nux, but um if Harmful Opinions was
just ignoring what they were saying,
then maybe they could make that
But I would say right now, he is directly engaging with everything
they're saying in response.
So, what are you losing out on? Like you just don't like the
truth to reply in public that you can't try to sweep in private
first. You're not That is not right for right of reply. That's
not what that is. >> to call it "door stepping" if you'd
like, but I think you'd suddenly be against getting comments
from involved parties. Leafy makes an interesting claim. The
The weird thing is really what they're advocating for and I mean,
you know, maybe it is the right idea at this point. They're kind
of advocating for an actual like ID system for
to be honest. Like Like where where could it go but that if that's
what you want? This is a bizarre statement. A key part of my
coverage and in fact, the ending of my second video is This is
literally like my opinion on this is I don't really want internet
ID, but ultimately probably if you want kids protected on the
internet, some form of internet ID needs to be introduced.
That's just it's almost certainly the case, right?
You can You can hate that. But if you want to prioritize kids
safety on the internet, which I assume a lot of people do, that's
probably where she has to go. And then you keep kids purely to
like ID only servers. >> is advocacy against overly invasive
measures. An explanation that negligence like this is what enables
it to happen. If parents aren't looking after their kids and
other adults aren't willing to do the bare minimum, then where
else can we go? There is an alternative. You could do the bare
minimum. Leafly and Mama Unko then do exactly what I said leads
to government involvement and private corporations clawing at
your data. If you don't want to hold like like parents as being
responsible for
for it, then I mean I don't know how you do it other than that.
Mhm. Online safety legislation is the government holding parents
responsible. It is the government saying it's the parents' job
and they haven't done it, therefore we get to step in. Same principle
for any attacks by private companies.
Well, holding parents responsible is definitely It is definitely
the option that I think a lot of people are like, "Oh, but why
should the parents No, they should. They need to. It is wrong
that they don't do that duty. But they don't do that duty. So,
what do you do about that? The government's answer is we do that
job instead. When people point out that parents should be doing
this and they don't, they never provide a way to fix that. A
little bit after that, Leafly elaborates. No, yeah. But as a
parent, you have the final control over everything that happens
to your kid. And that's my point. When I said that if that was
the point of my tweet.
And it wasn't even really about the next thing that the tweet
was actually completely I wasn't even thinking about like that
specific situation when I said that. It's just when I was thinking
all of the stuff that people were saying, it made me think like,
man, we could solve all this if parents just actually took care
of their kids. Mhm. Cool, Leafy. How do you make that happen?
If you do not provide an answer after saying that, your position
is actually let it happen. If your position is that bad things
are happening and parents should stop it and you stop there,
you are making an excuse. Also, I personally don't want to be
surrounded by Nuxes, even if there aren't any kids around. I
think that I think I I don't think you get to opt out of it there.
I think you actually just actually don't. You get to make one
or two decisions. Either I'm going to allow kids in my Discord,
I'm going to strictly mod anything that's inappropriate around
them, or I'm not going to allow kids in my Discord.
Like I don't I don't think it's responsible to allow under 18s
in a Discord and then to have in that Discord as a part of like
the legal TOS. Excuse me, it just seems super inappropriate completely
inappropriate to me.
Yeah, I don't I don't I'm not saying anything crazy, but I think
that seems to not click for people. >> problem. How does
parental supervision solve that? Leafy then seethes about Nux
Taku for an extended period of time. And having complained that
I didn't ask to talk to people, she complains that Nux Taku asked
to talk to her. Make it make sense. She then continues to seethe
that people are asking her about the Nux stuff. Mhm. Because
when I said that parents should be responsible, I never said
solely responsible. That's true of that one tweet. But she's
been talking about this for quite a while. In her commentary
on what happens to kids online and whose responsibility it is
and why restrictions are being put in place, she has in fact
said >> Like dude, this is all the fault of people not
taking care of their kids. This is freaking ridiculous. If you
[__] dude, if you [__] up your kids,
it shouldn't be my problem. They yap for a while and Mama Aiko
says that what we're asking for is for parents to do more than
what we see that they are doing because parents are just literally
handing technology to a kid and saying
Your responsibility your responsibility exists regardless of
what parents do. I hope they understand this. That it would be
really great if if the parents did everything, but you still
have a responsibility.
And if you don't want that responsibility,
just make 18 plus the rule.
It's so easy.
If you don't want any additional responsibility, just cut them
all out. Go wild. And how would she make that happen? She never
ever suggests anything. I don't have an answer for that either.
That's why I talk about what can be done instead. The government
has an answer to this request, too. It's legislation. These people
love to complain about that happening while literally asking
for it. Solve this. Solve this. This needs to be solved. They're
doing it. Later, Leafy talks about the people who are talking
about her. And see, this is my dilemma now, right? My dilemma
is do I do nothing so that they see, or do I farm them for content?
>> Allow me to present option C. Enact a policy of ban
Literally just literally just ban kids from your Discord, and
then nobody
In fact, I will I will literally myself
if you announce you're banning 18 plus if you're if you're doing
something like that, I will tweet like congratulations,
and not sarcastic congratulations. Like thank you for doing something
to protect kids on the internet. I appreciate it. Right? It's
so easy.
Their cope stream response to this was shameful, by the way,
earlier tonight. [__] Banning minors from your Discord
on sight, or get better mods. I I kind of feel like just not
giving them what they want is probably better. I want you to
instruct your mods to ban minors on sight, or get better mods.
Why wouldn't you do that? To own me and people like me? Seems
insane. But okay, if you wanted that to happen, you could make
it happen. >> Why would I argue with them? Why would I
entertain any of their arguments? Why would I watch the thing
when Because we had [__] happens with kids in your
Discord and your mods don't deal with It's basically going to
depend on whether or not Queen it is awake. Queen it's awake
and wants to play wild, I'm going to play wild. properly until
they're forced. >> If he's not awake >> It's so clear
what they want. >> I want you to ban minors or at least
get better I'll mods. I don't know how much clearer I can be.
I thought it was pretty obvious. Somebody link me the response
stream. If they've got a response stream tonight, I need the
response stream. Thank you. from the last two videos. I'm not
being presumptuous. This is a stream where Mama Octo just watched
them. They talk about sitting down and having conversations with
people and Leafy says Yeah, I mean that's how you actually solve
problems, right? Like is it about solving solving our problems,
solving our differences or is it about getting
some kind of I don't know, community to pat you on the back.
It's actually about getting you to fix your [__]
because someone told me about it and it's all [__]
up. If I've messed up and I've missed something like this happening
on my stuff, I would want to know so I could break the legs of
everyone involved, metaphorically of course. A little while after
Leafy expresses her sorrow at the change in the kind of person
she has to deal with. Cuz like a year ago, I was definitely a
lot more willing to talk to people and I was a lot more willing
to like engage with
you know, these kind of bad faith people. If I'm making these
suggestions and pointing these things out in bad faith, it doesn't
change whether my suggestions are good or not, does it? Why does
she not want to make things better? In the words of Shia LaBeouf,
just do it. That does mean I win and I'm doing this for Hasan
[__] so that means Hasan [__] wins. But
why isn't it the right thing to do? Hasan [__] is
not going to rest until no kids are groomed on the internet and
for some reason Asmongold's entire sphere of influence is being
brought to bear to stop this from happening.
Somebody make it make sense, okay? Hasan [__] himself
has has stated he will end child grooming on the internet and
he has deployed all resources towards this end. And for some
reason, Asmongold's entire sphere of influence is fighting this
as much as humanly possible. Somebody explain it to me, okay?
I don't get it. >> They're not They're not trying to communicate.
They're not trying to like have an honest conversation. They
just want to
hurt you for their benefit. >> Yeah. I want you to ban
kids who get better mods. If that hurts you, something's really
wrong. You don't even have to say it's 18+. You just have to
enforce it. When you say it's 18+, it can give the impression
that certain things are allowed that aren't, and the little will
out themselves thinking it's okay to, and then you just pop them.
There you go. There's one way to do it. I guess moving forward
here with the Discord, my only thing would just be to to be like,
"Listen, there's minors in there. You probably should just eat
them." What the [__] It's not my server, so obviously,
and it's not your server, I guess.
It's super easy to just have a rule. You don't even need 18+.
Although, I think my Discord rules say 18+.
I think it just says no minors as well.
Where do I see server guide? Where [clears throat] are my rules?
No slurs, no not safe for work, no physical threats or doxxing,
no minors, you must be 18 years old to participate in this server.
Boom. Easy. I don't even know what the rest
but I don't even know what the rest of the rules are. Ban topics,
explicit materials involving Dude, my my mods got it locked down,
okay? My mods I By the way,
I If somebody pointed out to me that it was a problem not to
have a certain rule, and I believe that rule is good, I think
I would add it. But, I am pretty negligent about the Discord.
So, thank God, my mod team I put I put smart people in charge,
okay? So, you know, they can do whatever they want, but I would
just suggest to avoid future videos like this. Just ban it. I
would never want to imply you're wrong and give those bad faith
actors ammo against you, but like, probably for me, I would just
ban all the minors. Probably for me, I'd just, you know, ban
the minors, cuz why would I want to talk Why would I want to
talk to minors? But hey, you do you. That's what I said. If you
want to talk to minors, I mean, that's your business. Jesus.
Look at it. Your life could be a lot easier if you just nuke
kids on site. I'm going insane. Yes, this is the whole point
of what I'm saying. >> What we're considering is like something
along the lines of you either have to be on Patreon >> Patreon's
a 13 plus site and age gate is applied to 18 plus creators. But
if you're not in that category, your solution is to get more
money instead of a lot of kids. It's 2026.
Minors have debit cards. Or uh you get like a really expensive
channel point reward and that like actually gets By the way,
minors had debit cards like 10 years ago, too. I might I couldn't
possibly have been the only minor with a credit card. Sorry,
not a credit card, a debit card. I couldn't have possibly been
that, >> Do access to the server. I wonder if that would
be the play. Like I That'll help with ban evasion. It won't help
you with the kid stuff. I don't know. But in the end, I'm going
to talk to I'm going to talk to, you know, Julio and and probably
Precure Hunter and probably just ask like and probably ask them
what they want to do with it. I know what Precure Hunter wants,
get rid of minors on site. I am genuinely losing it. They'll
have an extended discussion about stuff that won't really help
that much with their problem and Leafy gives a life lesson about
how people make >> People will will make Do we Do we think
Is it possible
that you just think if you're like doing, you know, some politics
to your like some politics adjacent stuff? Is there Is it possible
these people look at their analytics and Leafy goes like like
30% of my audience is below 18. Is it possible that that happens?
I don't think so.
But like I I can't
I sincerely can't think of any other reason that you would fight
so hard on this other than something like that. Like I don't
want to cut out young people from my audience because that'll
lead to them turning out and going somewhere where they're allowed.
I I just don't get it, right?
It It like yeah, I guess you could say harmful opinions wins.
If you ban 18 sorry, people under 18 from your Discord, but
I can't possibly be enough of a downside >> when it comes
to things like is that like a complete indictment of their character
that like oh yeah, they love they love
because they made a mistake on their Discord. Like I I don't
really think that's even remotely fair. I just want you to fix
your [__] No, I would I would agree. I think unfortunately
these days people are just so apt to quickly making snap choices.
And again, I think it would be solved if people did more talking
instead of just more being ready to poke and prod. Lynching.
Lynching, yes. Lynching, definitely. Yeah, I got that person
who said they sent a minor thigh pics in your Discord lynched.
That's sick and I'm proud of it. Leafy then talks about leaving
it up to the mods. Yeah, I mean it's really up to how they want
to do it. Like I'll I'll I'll ask them like what they want to
do. You can also lay down the law. You've done it before. When
people were saying the word "trannies", you stepped in. I showed
it earlier. Just do it again now. In my first video, I called
you spineless. I stand by that. Everybody's kind of flying by
the seat of their pants. They're learning as they go. Leafy,
as I showed earlier, your server originally
banned minors. You went backwards. You do that and the ordeal
with your mods. I'm just going to say, "Nice." What I've seen
going on in your stuff is insane. And we'll get back to that
in a bit, actually. And I I I think these people
they have no grace.
They expect absolute perfection from everybody and that's not
realistic to how people are. Mhm. I don't personally
What? Dude,
I think these people don't understand that even if there's like
a big Twitter thread, you can get out of this stuff. All you
All you have to do to respond to this is go, "Oh, you know what?
This did happen. We didn't have an 18+ rule. I should have had
it. I don't know like we had a discussion and we we like certain
people and we wanted to allow them and so we got rid of it and
it was like a bad idea and now we're getting we're we're going
back on that and we're going 18 plus again like only 18 year
olds only adults in the server. You you just say oh oops. I so
many people have grace for that. I don't know why these you understand
your whole thing so imagine you're in these people's minds okay
and it's like leftist attacking you. Do you know how unhinged
everybody on like I'm going to say my side of the aisle but like
harmful and the Candro's Shamu these guys who make the videos
and then like all the streamers you know how unhinged we would
all look if you there's no proof that you even saw this stuff
it happened once in your Discord and you just step in as soon
as you find out about it and go oh that's bad I don't like that
oops get getting rid of all of that ban ban ban ban anybody who's
a minor ban like basically ban anybody who's talking about being
DMs with them in any way boom oh oops done gone I don't want
You know how unhinged we would look if we just kept going hard
on you over
We would look terrible.
You could easily win if if we're as bad as you say if we're as
bad faith as you say if we're as up as you say
then all you would have to do is make the right call just apologize
you fix it and we would all look really bad if we just kept going
after you.
I don't know how to highlight this anymore for people.
Admitting a mistake correcting the mistake and moving forward
is not going to get you knocked off of the internet okay you
don't lose you don't you literally don't lose.
Right? It's that's not how it works you don't lose because you
made a mistake.
You can lose if you want to prolong a mistake forever and ever
and ever and you think some of these people would understand
that with their whole rationale for continuing to cover Colorgate
for weeks and weeks and weeks right? You want to keep prolonging
a mistake then yes you will get like borderline harassed forever
cuz you keep [__] up over and over and over again.
Expecting mods when they're alerted to get rid of someone who
says they're a kid and talking about fertile fanboys and breeding
to be perfection. What the [__] you trying to pull?
Maybe they'll grow up one day and learn that. Hey, you'll have
a lot more grown-ups around you if you ban kids. I'm used to
being the the least mature person in the room. Believable.
>> Hang on. Maybe Leafy does need to be destroyed. Anyway.
It's kind of such a weird shift to like everybody around me is
being like a freaking child. Yeah, cuz you welcome them to your
Discord. Hold on. Hold on. I'm guessing that is a bad faith representation.
I'm guessing they were like mocking that stupid clip and it was
meant to be a joke that they did one time and they were like
gross, that person's gross, and we all move on, right? I'm guessing
with the binky and she And your mods won't take appropriate pass
by or whatever. >> action unless pressed. A little bit
later, Mama Aiko says something good. Moving forward, if somebody
says they're 15, I personally just want to give them any quarter.
>> Yeah, good. I mean, I I I feel I'm not >> Sure.
My first video was about this [__] happening repeatedly
with mods being pinged. I'm not perfect either. Maybe I [__]
up somewhere. I want to know so I can fix it. But I've decided
to be a public figure, small as I am. So if someone wants to
point that out with a video, and especially if they want to point
out because they've seen there's resistance to doing the right
thing, and they want to force it, fair enough. First example
I gave in my first video about an interaction I found on it acceptable,
I literally said, "Maybe mods didn't know about it, but it's
still a problem because the server is set up to facilitate it."
I don't think that's too crazy. >> I would hope that um
if somebody sees somebody claiming to be a minor, they would
ping me in my my mod chat. Great. And Mama Aiko, from what I
watched, was generally on board when I made suggestions along
these lines, ish. Mama Aiko knows what's right, but he's a He
wants to keep his bridges safe. He's going to be soft even when
he knows what's right and wrong. That is gross. If someone's
going to drop you because you don't just go, >> "Well,
you know, it's not up to me. It's not up to you." Why do you
want to be connected to that person? You talk about other people
being clout goblins, look in the mirror. Yeah, I'm fine with
um I'm fine with operation Hazelnut Hollow and just nuking all
of the minors out there. I'm like totally fine with that, yeah,
personally. Then do it. You did it for trans people. You can
do it for kids. No, yeah. But it's really up to you know, again,
it's it's up to what they want to do, how they want to handle
it. They have their own ideas for how things should go. Mhm.
Hello. Hello, Earthly Leaflet. Here's PreCure. She then says,
And if like it's if I could tell them what to do, then it would
actually be my Discord, right? No problem there. We've seen you
making decisions and you might crazy. Three days ago claimed
that you go above their head to make decisions. You are not as
hand
Yeah, I don't know why they're actually >> he pretends
to be. I made them wrap up. Now, there's been a lot of talk about
getting rid of minors or not. And that distracts from another
issue I alluded to earlier.
He all could be a hero and save these
Save the kids in these pedo Discords by offering his expertise.
His hacking expertise or his moderating expertise. Which one?
>> PreCure's suggestion to ban on site for minors is good,
but if you don't do that, PreCure is a problem. You say it's
jokes. You say it's bait for me. I don't buy it. This person
cannot be [clears throat] a mod in a server that welcomes kids.
Let's talk about PreCure's. Actually, it's about ethics and grooming.
An adult got groomed by a minor because he was too to listen
to people when they told him to just block the minor, asks Norlex.
PreCure responds with a nodding gif. We have posts by the minor
in this chat of them being aggressive unprompted. They share
a post by the person who said they were 14 and then 15. This
is from the minor soliciting the adult. And that was less than
a month since I I can't imagine making these arguments. I do
the joking thing with YandereDev or whatever cuz YandereDev is
clearly like totally
I I would never ever make like the argument that oh, these people
were like provocative in a Discord.
So, he had no choice but to go It's like, dude, come on, man.
Since the minor had joined the server, not seeing the joke, can
you explain it? I think it's kind of weird as well, but the adult
was pathetic enough and the minor pushy enough that it's not
unbelievable. Prozd Madra steps in to say, I think the important
things to notice here are minor and adult. Only one of those
can really be at fault here. Minor can do wrong, of course, but
just ban and move on then. The mod says, "Their ages aren't actually
that different. It's like 14 versus early 20s."
Okay. I did.
I'm sorry, that person's out of my
Uh that's woah.
Yeah, legally it'll be the adult's fault, no matter what, but
morally they both seem to be at fault. Prozd Madra responds to
the no matter what message and says, "Exactly. You can do what
you want, but I'll be suggest that you stop painting the minor
as the aggressor here, even if it's true. Woah. The only one
who can truly be at fault here is the adult, and that's that.
It doesn't look good when you talk about the minor being the
baddie. I can only speak for myself, though. Why can't anyone
have any conviction? It's sad." PreCure Hunter says, "I care
more about the truth than the law." Prozd Madra
It's like 14 versus early 20s. >> "I can understand that.
I'm just saying it doesn't look great. I understand that the
minor must have been a creep and definitely did wrong, but putting
any focus on the actions of the minor does not look great. That's
all I'm saying." Later, my second video is uploaded and PreCure
talks about the situation so far to someone who wants a quick
rundown. Within that, they say that in my second
I'm talking about their logic not being good enough because they
said it's possible that the adult was groomed by the teenager.
They say they banned 15th watcher on the basis of a preponderance
of evidence. You should have banned them because there is a message
from them saying they sent a minor their thigh
clothed as it was because the minor was pursuing them. No need
for waiting probabilities or legal jargon. You say that, you
get whacked. Maybe it didn't happen. Maybe the pic wasn't that
bad. No, you ban them. And they elaborate stating the real problem
with someone like me. The real overarching problem here though
is that people don't like dealing with people who are undecided
or entertaining unorthodox positions. Like it's obviously inflammatory
to think that the child was grooming the adult. And if you by
definition think that it can only go the other way, then you'll
bristle strongly at the mere suggestion of that. They're meaning,
yeah, this is just a meme, yeah, haha, four chains. Then they
explain the reason for ban that I showed you earlier. Kitty Dess
amongst that says, "You think the underaged aren't the ones who
are uncontrollably horny? You want to pry them off each other
with crowbars." Sure, teens are hormonal, but we're talking about
moderating a Discord server where minors and adults interact.
PreCure responds and explains that their comment about age was
not a joke. Yeah, that too. Oh, hold on.
Keep going, but
Thank you very much Hamster for the 500 >> That's why I
said it's not like it's an 8-year-old comment. If you're sending
pics to an 8-year-old, then obviously it's grooming. If you're
sending it to a horny teenager, that specifically requested them,
that's less obvious. It was literally just about how plausible
each story would be. Prezl says, "But again, still a minor."
And PreCure responds, "Of course, but if you have identical moral
considerations for a 15-year-old and an 8-year-old simply because
they're both underage, you're living in a fantasy world that
doesn't actually exist. We're talking about banning someone from
Dis
Almost five viewers, keep going. Let's go. You almost have five.
>> scored for being a creep. You don't have to measure
which fraction of a ban you give them. Just hit them. No need
to hesitate or wrestle with the philosophy of grooming. You nailed
them eventually, but you were struggling. People chit-chat and
the Precure ends up talking about the problems with the age of
consent in general. Very epic Reddit chungus, my dude. This person
cannot be a moderator on a server that welcomes kids. How the
[__] is that controversial?
So this is the response I guess it's from Mama Aiko and Leafy
at the same time. Looks like Oh, that's not Mama Aiko. That's
a different person. No, that's Mama Aiko, right? With the octopus
stuff.
And then Leafy's apparently here, too. >> Flat. Okay. The
Leafy Discord kerfuffle.
Under the tea podcast. Who is this supposed to be? This is Mama
Aiko and Mizu Tamari. Okay, so this is Mama Aiko and not Leafy
in this case. Okay. >> Nikandros and Harmful Opinions were
trying to take like a swing at Nux, and when they realized that
nobody actually gave a [__] they immediately turned
to Leafy for some reason.
Not only did they turn to Leafy, they also uh was yesterday,
I believe, uh Nikandros decided to take a hit at what he calls
the Brat Hog Kersh, which that's what he called her, not me.
I'm just repeating I did see I did see that Nikandros was taking
shots at the Brat Hog Kersh and her diabetic comas, okay? I did
see that. >> decided to say. So um they're trying to swipe
at anybody that like goes
that is not like conforming to the opinion that they want. I
I also have to say because Nikandros made this joke on Twitter,
like I'm fine with jokes,
but when you were actively saying like people shouldn't be making
like
jokes on Discord, you probably shouldn't post a picture of Leafy
and say this brat needs correction.
Yeah, I found that kind of funny. I'm going to be honest. It's
just like okay. You're [laughter] getting upset with a lot of
the jokes that are being made in Nux Taku's Discord server and
now Leafy's Discord server. But the brat needs correction is
literally like a an a meme in anime culture for like >> It's
a meme. Yeah, it's a meme and it's just like my man, there could
be kids
I'm joking about a 40-year-old woman while these are sweeping
for actual children talking among people who lust for cartoon
children. Yeah. Yeah. It's on Twitter and you could be exposing
them to this joke and that sounds
and when people like clip that and say that sounds I'm going
to be like yeah, I know, but that's literally what these people
are saying. So I I'm confused right now. Why is it okay for him
to make this joke
It's like the performative
Like do you think that you could tell either they didn't watch
the video or they're too stupid to understand it. Um, it's a
performative here. No, Nikacado's didn't build an audience that's
built on like appealing to kids. Obviously.
Obviously. Oh, now this guy's being
Oh god.
Apparently the bot stuff didn't make me upset so he had to come
up with something else. Weirdo. Weirdo.
Dude, DG Gears are weird as man. But it's not okay when he's
trying to call out people for what he assumes is serious crimes.
Thank you Noir for five the New Zealand Australia conspiracy
What was I saying? Okay, so Nikacado's doesn't build like an
audience of kids. He doesn't use tags that appeal to kids. He
doesn't use thumbnails that appeal to kids, right? He just he's
a commentary channel. Nux spent a bunch of time and then he essentially
like has people who are kids in all of his spaces. He has non
18 plus spaces and continues to like basically build an empire
on
like their shared love of
It's I don't know. I don't know, man. I don't know. It seems
like a pretty It's just very different. Trying to pretend they're
the same thing is goofy as [__] Makes no sense, unlike
birds being drones,
uh which is 100% true. Oh, why would I This is what I said earlier,
Rooty. Like I just I don't get like it's not like minors do good
conversation.
Yeah, yeah. I don't I don't get it,
Some could term it an EPI empire that needs to be exposed. Yeah,
it is It is like that. It is It is just like that. It is a EPI
It's an EP empire, okay? He's a very
Some might call Some might call Nux Taku the the EPI king, okay?
The king of EPI.
EP king. Some of them at least. Some of those pigeons in New
York City, maybe. They're all watching those citizens shoveling
snow for 45 bucks an hour. We have a giant metal pigeon in my
city.
But yeah, for for some reason Nux Taku Andros just tweeted
Yeah, I'll pull it up for chats. For anybody that didn't see
it, cuz nobody can not believe me. It is It was a little bizarre.
I'm just going to be honest. I I like double took because I was
like, "What the fuck?" I should have full screen one. You can't
about like jokes and then say [__] like this. No.
Is it Are the jokes a
But hold on. Hold on. You can totally [__] about
actually exposing real kids
or any kind of like images, drawn or otherwise. You can [__]
about that and make this joke.
Right? Do you guys understand how tangible it is? Oh, wow. Thank
you so much. Thank you so much, Nux Andros, for that. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you for the definition of Jesus Christ. Well,
I got it wrong, it looks like.
I got it wrong, it seems. Gross.
Anyway, we understand where the difference is here, right? That
there's real condemnation, real disgust, real concern with regards
to the Leafy Discord, less so than the Nux Discord. The Nux Discord's,
frankly,
career-ending. But,
also the Nux EPI stuff.
Like, these are all These are all real concerns. All of Nicandro's
stuff has been on real concerns.
To say that he can't make a joke like a a joke in that environment
is crazy. Makes no >> problem or they not?
They're only a problem when you're in a Discord server where
minors are involved. But,
because it's Twitter, it's obviously the open public, which,
in my personal opinion, is a little bit worse than a Discord
server filled with less people, uh because there is a likelihood
that you'll encounter a multitude of children on Twitter.
Uh also, chat, before we
We We all understand that there's a difference between, like,
one, if Nicandro's was like a children's creator for a long time,
maybe there's some argument there. Also, it's like it's just
text, so it's a little little bit harder to make the
What What Nicandro's is talking about is, like, verified. Kids
have been exposed. Kids are being exposed actively. And you're
aware of it and doing nothing.
Right? E- getting started into that, I just wanted to share you
my little hyperfixation of the day because I thought it was really
funny. Oh, boy. >> Uh so, if anybody has ever played Stardew
Valley, Stardew Valley, to this day, is still an ex-
Okay. Well,
unfortunately, I've got too many I've got I'm balancing like
too many active creeks, or I could maybe
start focusing on this a little bit
I feel like right now I I don't have the bandwidth for these
people as well. I can't I can't crack I can't crack the the egg
that is Hutch
and focus on these people at the same time. It's kind of difficult,
but this has been fine. I've enjoyed going over this. There's
one more timestamp, by the way, where they're reviewing a little
bit of Harmful Opinions video, okay? Also, Ako friend Elf Pyre
Eva was an associate of Biddy Cat, someone who
Okay, misinput, mistyped. I don't even know what the [__]
is happening here, >> 1.2 is probably fine. And here's
what I will say, now that I have seen like his arguments from
his third video, walking back retrospectively,
I feel like I'll do a decent job trying to explain what he was
kind of trying to go for here, and then I will explain why I
think that that still doesn't work out very well because of how
he chose to do it, basically. Yeah, anyway, go ahead.
Oh, a VTuber is actually going to take a look at that Nux Taku
video. Oh, she didn't look at it at all. And even just yapping
around it and dodging anything where she'd have to think or have
any sort of spine, she still managed to disappear in the >> very
upset that she's not actually like engaging with it. Yeah. Oh,
he pretends to be a cartoon on
Well, that she was sweeping for it without engaging with it.
Yes.
Give her Wait, Nikandros.
I I feel like No, I'm not going to say it. I was going to make
a joke about how you need to carve out an exception for Nyaners
right now. But no, Nyaners also did something like this. I don't
even want to really read read this whole thing, but Harmful Opinions
made a video exposing her, which resulted in her LEAVING THE
INTERNET. OH.
SO, the Biddy Cat person left the internet. It's prob- probable
that
through a a friend, through an association, she's aware of Harmful
Opinions and him going after people and making them leave the
internet, more or less. Okay. >> on the internet and has
all the fire in the world to just spit at every other thing she
looks at, clearly understands how filth rots its surroundings
and radiates outwards, affecting us all. But on the matter of
the corruption of the next generations online, is fixated on
the culpability of the parents, ignoring entirely that what she's
looking at is the next wave of parents who aren't going to look
after their kids and in fact will think all of what happens in
the dark corners of Discord is fine. These are the So, I hate
this argument just in general, right? Of the well, these these
parents aren't teaching these kids and then these kids won't
teach their kids. I'm like, yeah, I guess that sucks. I'm not
their parent and I'm not going to step up to be their parent
cuz I chose not to have kids specifically because I don't like
them. Also, I just I have to mention this and you two can probably
see it. Chat can't see it because it's off screen.
There's a There's a Jacob Galler video off in the corner that's
50 minutes long, 40 minutes long. It's titled I am Jesus Christ
and other games about
Oh my gosh. And there's a picture of a big daddy from BioShock
in the
I might have to listen to that tomorrow. Dude, wait, is this
really Pisco in Chud's chat?
Apparently, apparently Pisco went to Chud's chat recently said
this. I didn't see this. Someone told me I caused your friendship
with Nicholas Deorio to fall apart and I just want to say from
the bottom of my heart, I don't know who that is. >> Pisco
still the Who is Nicholas Deorio? Who the is Nicholas Deorio?
I just want to I'm still blocked on Twitter. I just want to say,
who the is that? I don't I literally don't know. I literally
don't know who that is.
Ah, good times. Good times.
Pisco getting chippy, throwing elbows all over the place, man.
That looks pretty funny. You love to see
>> I need to start prepping for my Saturday live house.
>> you watch Riot house, did you watch the beginning of
the stream, go to sleep, wake up, and now you're back for the
end of the stream? Is that what I'm seeing here? >> I don't
mean to derail things, but I saw that in the corner of my eye.
I'm like, that just Cool, cool, cool.
That is awesome. It threw me for a loop. Uh thank you internet
zit master for $10. Worth noting on the Nikocado thing regarding
Nux, he was posting about career ending stuff back in October
25th of last year. Dude only wanted content from the get-go.
I mean, that's at this point, like that's kind of how I feel
it is. I mean, like he's going to come out and say, "No, I wanted
to go on this crusade against" And it's just like I I at this
point, I'm not quite sure how much I believe that based off of
how these people act. It's just like there's a way to go after
real predators and I just this isn't it. This isn't it and I
feel like content creators always get up. Uh you know, it's nice
to point out and say, "Oh my gosh, that person is evil and gross
and I don't like them." But like unless you're willing to involve
the police, eh.
I don't know. I don't know, man. What? I I'm sorry. And maybe
it's cuz it's a little late. I'm not paying attention. She said
the only way you should care is if you're willing to involve
the police. >> quite sure how much I believe that based
off of how Nux, he was posting about career ending stuff back
in October 25th of last year. Dude only wanted content from the
get-go.
I mean, that's at this point, like that's kind of how I feel
it is. I mean, like he's going to come out and say, "No, I wanted
to go on this crusade against" And it's just like I I at this
point, I'm not quite sure how much I believe that based off of
how these people act. It's just like there's a way to go after
real predators and I just this isn't it. This isn't it and I
feel like content creators always get up. Uh you know, it's nice
to
I So, I'm totally fine with this
What part Like what If we were to walk through Dude, I feel like
you shouldn't be able to say this and avoid a conversation with
Nikocado.
I I can moderate a conversation with you and Nikocado. I'm a
mod co. I'm offering. I would I would moderate a conversation
with you and Nikocado, but you will have to answer questions
and they would be questions like which part of the video, which
fact in the video did you think didn't matter or was underwhelming?
Which like allegation made in the video was underwhelming for
you or didn't matter? Do you not care about kids being exposed
like en masse to
like content? Is that not a big deal? Is it not a big deal because
other YouTubers did it? Uh can you name YouTubers who did it
at a scale that Nux
And then would you excuse all of them?
Like I I would moderate this conversation. I just I feel like
there's no way and I would be fair. I just feel like there's
no way that Momawko person like actually wants that to happen.
I feel like there's no chance
that they want to have like a tangible conversation. Sorry, a
substantive conversation about this. Cuz you could say these
things and you you'd say them in a YouTube video and never engage
and just pray that other people don't see it.
But like
I would never not watch the video or or watch the video like
that and then go, "Well, this guy is stupid. He did a horrible
job."
I just I can't, man. It's such It's such an obvious shot video.
Point out and say, "Oh my gosh, that person is evil and gross
and I don't like them." But like unless you're willing to involve
the police
Oh, wait.
This isn't it. This isn't it and I feel like content creators
always get up. You know, it's nice to point out and say, "Oh
my gosh, that person is evil and gross and I don't like them."
But like unless you're willing to involve the police
That's what he's doing. He's saying, "Look at how evil and gross
this person is. We should all dislike them. We should all not
support them." Yeah, he's he's literally not saying that this
guy did a crime. He's saying, "This guy is a total piece of sh
and it's outside of our current capacity to censor or do something
about and it seems like people will have made money through this
incredibly like disgusting immoral behavior.
So, we should all point at this piece of sh and socially penalize
him in a way we can't legally penalize him. What's confusing?
Would this not be the same thing? So, when Asmongold wanted to
dox and get fired all the people who laughed Charlie Kirk's stupid
[__] gushing throat, is that now that's like totally
against the rules? Oh, well, I guess What are you So, they're
bad. Okay, so they're bad. What do you want me to do? What do
you want someone to do about it? So, they're bad. What are we
supposed to do?
I It's just It seems so inconsistent from place to place. Now,
I don't know Mama Akos position on that. Maybe she's all like
I'm guessing there's going to be like oh, there's absolutely
no room for that. That's so disgusting.
I don't know. I don't know, man.
Unless you're going to involve the police, I don't know. I don't
know, man.
So, you know,
you know what I mean?
the people who are going to be the adults your kids are around
in real life. Where are the parents? She asks. Where are the
parents at? Where they at? She knows where they are. A huge chunk
is talking about that. All these influences in the world that
didn't show up 5 years ago. The negligent or messed up parent
of today was the kid being corrupted yesterday. It's a vicious
cycle that
They're all just going to Dude, the funny thing is is with that
think before you sleep video in Acatros, they're not just So,
that's going to happen. But, what's truly disgusting about that
is they will literally talk about the activist judge. They'll
have no coherent thought process. They'll just say activist judge,
activist judge, activist judge. They won't investigate any of
the evidence. They won't investigate Tekton's conduct, why how
he came out said I have totally exonerating evidence, didn't
present that in public, didn't present that in court, went to
court, totally humiliated himself. None of that matters, okay?
Cuz apparently this judge was racist or something. Apparently.
And that makes it so she can't oversee this case. Or she just
advocated for victims of abuse. I can't remember which one. But,
apparently that's the most tangible substantive factor that they
can name from this case is this judge was biased. >> It needs
to be broken somewhere unless you're just okay with living in
hell. I find that saying, "Not my fault, tee hee." is little
com- That's just the field she works in. Okay, so it's totally
Oh, fantastic. >> collapses around you. Let's be fair,
though. People wanting you to address stuff that has nothing
to do with you is probably stressful. I could hear the tension
in Leafy's voice. She sounded like a 3-year-old with a severe
temporomandibular deformity for the entire video. But, >> I
want to say, by the way,
I feel like if you actually want somebody to take you seriously,
starting off by at them definitely isn't the way to go. I was
actually thinking the same thing. I was like, Bro, okay, I could
I could believe this. I could understand this. I agree with it,
actually.
In other places.
I agree with it in other places when you're not doing entertainment.
If I truly just wanted you to like fix your Discord, I could
not insult you and just say, "These are the problems. This is
what I think you should do. If you have a good argument against
that, let me know, but otherwise, this is what should be done."
Guys making content, okay?
Now, if you're ever going to say, "Well, no, I'm going to let
kids get groomed in my Discord because that guy was mean to me."
If you want to be that person, if that's where you want to go
with this,
I don't know what to tell you. You sound like a worse person.
Right? Yes, this guy made fun of you, and so you allowed kids
to be groomed around you. I don't I can't imagine. Okay, you're
just you're just going to define yourself by your enemies so
much that you'll you'll become you'll enable child abuse, you'll
enable child
just to avoid
I guess acquiescing to this mean guy's point of view.
I Maybe just have your own thought process, decide what's right
and wrong for yourself. I don't know. You know, for someone that's
trying to persuade
Okay, I think there's a lot of this. It looks like this is a
There's a lot of this. I don't think I could do the whole cope
session tonight.
I'm probably going to look to end right now. What are we 9 hours
in? Yeah, we basically went 9 hours tonight. Okay, 9 hours was
a lot.
I'm a little tired now, I myself
am am going to go be the king of my own EP empire, but a different
kind of EP, okay? Not EPI, just sleepy, just tired.